welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford school of
medicine today my guest is Dr vivc
Murthy Dr vivc Murthy is a medical
doctor and acting Surgeon General of the
United States as Surgeon General of the
United States Dr Murthy oversees more
than 6,000 dedicated Public Health
officers whose job is to protect protect
promote and Advance our nation's Public
Health Dr Murthy received his bachelor's
degree from Harvard University and his
medical degree from the Yale University
School of Medicine today's discussion
covers some of the most important issues
in public health not just within the
United States but worldwide including
nutrition and the Obesity crisis as well
as food additives and why certain food
chemicals and additives are allowed in
the United States versus in other
countries we also discuss mental health
the youth mental Mental Health crisis
the adult Mental Health crisis and the
global crisis of loneliness and
isolation we also talk about corporate
interests that is whether or not big
food and big Pharma Industries actually
impact the research Andor decisions that
the US Surgeon General takes in his
directives toward public health and of
course we discussed some of the major
public health events that occurred over
the last 5 years and the current and
future landscape of how to restore Faith
both in public health officials in
public health policy and science more
generally by the end of today's episode
you not only will have learned a
tremendous amount about public health
and why you hear the particular Public
Health directives that you do but also
how to better interpret future Public
Health directives you will also come to
learn that as Surgeon General Dr Murthy
has both an extremely challenging job
but one that he meets with a tremendous
amount of both rigor and compassion
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is how however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is Maui Nei venison
Maui Nei venison is the most
nutrient-dense and delicious red meat
available I've spoken before on this
podcast in Solo episodes and with guests
about the need to get approximately 1
gram of high quality protein per pound
of body weight each day for optimal
nutrition now there are many different
ways that one can do that but a key
thing is to make sure that you're not
doing that by ingesting excessive
calories Maui Nei venison has the
highest density of quality protein per
calorie and it achieves that in
delicious things like ground Meats
venison steaks jerky and bone broth I
particularly like the ground venison I
make those into venison burgers probably
five times a week or more I also like
the jerky for its convenience especially
when I'm traveling or I'm especially
busy with work and know that I'm getting
an extremely nutrient-dense high quality
source of protein if you'd like to try
Maui Nei venison you can go to mauii
Venison dcom huberman and get 20% off
your first order again that's Maui
venison
docomond to get 20% off today's episode
is also brought To Us by Roka Roa makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that are of
the absolute highest quality I've spent
a life time working on the biology the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges order
for you to be able to see clearly in
different environments Roa understands
the biology of the visual system and has
designed their eyeglasses and sunglasses
so that you always see with Crystal
Clarity originally their glasses were
designed for performance that is for
running and cycling and for sport and
indeed they can still be used for
performance they won't slip off your
face if you get sweaty they're extremely
lightweight but I should mention that
Roa eyeglasses and sunglasses come in
some of the Aesthetics more typically
associated with performance glasses like
those cyborg style glasses but they also
have a number of styles that you would
be perfectly comfortable wearing out to
dinner or to work I wear readers at
night or when I drive and I wear
sunglasses during the day if I happen to
be driving into bright light or outside
and it's just overwhelmingly bright I do
not wear sunglasses when I do my morning
sunlight viewing to set my circadian
rhythm and I suggest that you do the
same if you'd like to try Roa eyeglasses
or sunglasses you can go to Roka r.com
and enter the code hubman to save 20%
off your first order again that's Roa r
and enter the code huberman at checkout
and now for my discussion with Dr vivc
Murthy Dr vivec Murthy welcome thanks so
much Andrew and please call me vi I'm
informal okay VI my understanding based
on my internet search is that the role
of the US Surgeon General is to provide
scientific information on how to improve
health and reduce risk of illness and
injury do I have that correct that is
correct what are some other roles that
you play that perhaps would not come up
in a a top uh top hit uh Google search
that that I ought to be aware of and
that our audience ought to be aware of
well here's how I I generally explain to
people there there two primary roles the
Surgeon General has one is to engage
with the public and make sure that
people know about critical public health
issues that they so they know what they
are how to protect themselves and their
families this second role of the General
is lesser known but it's equally as
important which is to oversee one of the
eight Uniformed Services in the US
government and that is the United States
Public Health Service many people are
familiar with the Army the Navy the Air
Force we also have the US Public Health
Service which is 6,000 officers they
include doctors nurses physical
therapists pharmacists Public Health
Engineers a whole range of of healthcare
folks and their job is to protect our
nation from public health threats so
when Ebola came on the scene in
2014 in a major way in West Africa we
sent hundreds of officers to West Africa
to set up the Monrovia medical unit in
Liberia to treat people with li with uh
with ebola domestically when there are
hurricanes or tornadoes we dispatch
officers and deploy them to go help
strengthen the social the public health
infrastructure but also to provide
Direct Care we deployed thousands of
officers during coid so these officers
uh I'm incredibly proud of them uh they
could be doing lots of stuff you know
outside government in the private sector
probably making a whole lot more money
and getting a you know working a lot
less hard but they're really committed
to protecting the public health of the
nation so I have the privilege of
overseeing that service as Surgeon
General and those those are those are
the jobs that I've signed up for in this
role got it I was not aware of that role
and if I understood correctly these
people um these Public Health officers
um that presumably are made up of
physician
and licensed psychologists and nurses
and so forth um you said they could be
making uh substantially higher incomes
in the private sector but the work that
they're doing with you is their sole
career at this point they're completely
devoted to that or they're doing this as
a side Hustle No they are full-time uh
government employees and and members of
the Public Health Service their day job
is often in public health agencies where
they're embedded in communities helping
day-to-day to advance public health and
during times of emergency uh we deploy
them uh you know and and they're they're
extraordinarily well trained uh they're
experienced at dealing with adversity
but they bring a combination of skill
and heart to their work and you really
need both to be effective at public
health I'm glad that you mention the
word emergency because in preparing for
our discussion today it occurred to me
that in this uh list of roles that uh
your title assumes that scientific
information on how to improve health
comes first then you mentioned emergency
so what I'd like to talk about first is
Health not lack of Health but Health you
know so often we hear about um the
Mental Health crisis but what we're
really talking about is the lack of
Mental Health crisis AKA mental illness
and rarely do we hear for instance what
constitutes mental health we hear what
constitutes mental illness whereas in
the domain of physical health there's a
lot of information out there about how
to be more physically healthy
cardiovascular exercise resistance
exercise yoga typee exercise Mobility
Etc and of course some people have
physical health ailments and there's a
lot of information in terms of how to
deal with that as well but what I would
like to know before we get into the long
list of issues that uh our nation
confronts um everything from obesity to
food additives to mental health
issues what is going well in other words
in the last let's say five 5 to 10 years
have there been any areas of physical
health and mental health Improvement in
the US at large that we can attribute to
some of the public health initiatives uh
directly so that's a really good
question and let me just also say about
the very first point you raised that
you're absolutely right that we have
operated primarily through an illness
frame when we look at health and in my
mind that's only one half of the
equation right so when we are talking
about physical illness for example uh
you know as a doctor I learned how to
diagnose and treat someone with diabetes
or with high blood pressure or with
coronary heart disease but we also know
that even if I don't have diabetes or
coronary heart disease uh or high blood
pressure even if I don't have any
diagnosable medical condition I may not
be at an optimal level of physical
health right I may not be able to for
example walk around the block without
getting shorter breath I may not be able
to play with my kids because my physical
fitness and stamina is is insufficient I
may not be able to lift my luggage when
I go to the airport because I don't have
enough strength in my body yet I
wouldn't have a diagnosable mental
illness so I think it's easier to
understand there with physical health
that we're not just aiming for lack of
illness we're aiming to optimize our
physical health the same is true with
mental health and I think when we talk
about mental health people think we're
just the sole goal here is to prevent
diagnosable mental illness that is one
goal to both prevent and to manage uh
mental illness when it arises but we
also need to recognize there's a whole
other half of the spectrum where there
people who may not have diagnosable
mental illness but are not operating
optimally in their lives and that's
detracting from their fulfillment from
their functionality like in not just at
work but also in their communities and
in their families and so I think part of
the conversation that that I want us to
have as a country is about how to
optimize mental health and well-being
and that is includes preventing Mental
Illness but it is much broader and
bigger uh than that alone great yeah I
think it's so important that we
recognize that um treating disease is
critical obviously but that there's a
lot that can be done to improve one's
Health even in the absence of any known
disease and um and you've got all these
officers these incredible Physicians and
uh nurses and uh people at uh your
disposal I My Hope Is that they would
also be accessible for and currently
carrying out um efforts to transmit
information to people about hey here are
the things that you can do every day
every week every month in order to make
your life as as healthy as possible um
as well as you know rushing in under
conditions of you know Public Health
crisis yeah it's a good good point and
it's certainly you know many of our
officers do focus on this broader rubric
around well-being but it's part of how
we need I think the the broader health
system and public health system to
operate even outside of government
and this I think will require
significant change and shift in how we
think about our jobs like when I went to
medical school the vast majority of the
focus was on diagnosing and treating
illness it was much much less focused on
thinking about how to enhance
well-being and when you ask talk to
people in their lives it becomes clear
that they want to do more than just
prevent diagnosable illness they they
want to be able to walk their their
child down the aisle they want and have
the endurance to do that they want to be
able to uh be independent often and
carry their groceries or carry their
luggage um this is why I think we've got
to broaden our focus in in public health
and look when I came into this role um
by the way I was not expecting to serve
in government this was not part of some
5 10 30 year plan uh when I was a a kid
I was interested in medicine but I
always thought I was going to practice
medicine you know like my dad did and
like my like the clinic my mom ran you
know set up put up a shing sing Le see
patients and uh be a primary care doctor
and and feel good about the work I was
doing but what happened to me along the
way is uh you know I I trained in
medicine I got interested in technology
spent seven years building a technology
company uh that was focused on health I
got I was I became increasingly worried
about the way we were delivering
Healthcare and it felt like our
healthare system was broken people who
needed care couldn't get it it was often
too expensive to get care we were
focusing on treatment solely and not
enough on prevention so I started
getting involved in in advocating for a
Better Health Care system with doctors
around the country when despite all that
I still never thought I would work in
government but in 2013 uh is when
President Obama's team had reached out
to me and asked if I'd be interested in
considering the position of Surgeon
General and what was interesting to me
about this position is it's actually
very different from most positions uh
that are appointed by President and
government and that it's supposed to be
an independent position so my agenda the
issues I choose to take on are not
determined by a president or a party
they're determined by science and the
public interest uh and that's what's
what guides me you know and that's what
that's what guided me in that first term
when I served and when President Biden
asked me to come back and serve as
Surgeon General a second time that's
what's guided me here too um so Biden um
is not sending you notes saying hey
could you put some effort into uh you
know getting messages out about you know
Co or could you put more effort into um
getting your team over to Maui to deal
with the you know the you know the
tragedy there and which is a long Arc
tragedy right we get the news in a in a
in a blast of this happened and then the
next blast comes in about something else
and we forget that there are physical
and mental health crises that are
ongoing um and and then I have to
imagine then start to overlap with one
another or is it so is it your decision
um where and how to deploy the financial
and and Human Resources like okay we're
going to put 10 people on Maui yeah
we're going to um put uh you know five
people in the Central States you know
going around talking to um major
organizations about what they need to do
to prepare for this winter is that how
it works or are you getting memos and um
in other words who's your boss everyone
has a boss at some level mine are is are
the listeners of of this podcast at some
level I work for them it used to also be
my bulldog
um but my my boss my wife and my two
kids who are five and seven they I do
what they tell me to got it got it so um
but how we make our decisions in the
office actually it's a bit different uh
with those two roles so on with with the
second one with overseeing the
commission Corp our 6,000 officers they
the the decisions about how and when we
deploy officers are collaborative right
so I you know we work with other
colleagues throughout the Department of
Health and Human Services we work with
people in FEMA across the administration
but we also work with States so
sometimes states often often States will
put in a request and say hey we need
support here uh can you help so we'll
work with colleagues across our
department to say okay well we can
mobilize our commission core officers
what assets can you mobilize and then
collectively we will send a team out
there so for example we have officers
helping in Maui right now uh
particularly with mental health needs uh
which are I worry only going to continue
to grow over the weeks and months ahead
on the other side of the house when when
it comes to deciding which issues we
engage with the public on like in this
case mental health has been a big Focus
uh area for me on on that front well we
certainly you know are open to
suggestions from the public members of
Congress sometimes say hey can you help
the public understand about this issue
you know a lot of people have ideas and
opinions but the decision about which
issues to focus on those are our offices
uh and to me that's important because
part of the reason over time I believe
the public came to have some degree of
faith and trust in the office office is
because they hope that the office was
functioning the way you hope your doctor
is functioning which is being an
independent source of information for
you uh and a source that has your best
interest at heart that's not being
pulled aside by political interests or
by other agendas but the primary agenda
is how can I help your health and so for
me like we have to make an independent
assessment there and say okay where is
the need uh the greatest tier where can
we make the biggest difference sometimes
we may not build an initiative on an
issue and that doesn't mean that that
ISU is not important or that it's not
affecting a lot of people but we have to
make hard decisions about where to put
limited resources and so when I was a
Surgeon General the the first time one
of the big areas I focused on was the
opioid crisis uh that we were dealing
with as well as the E ecigarette use
among youth because we were seeing a
dramatic increase uh among kids in
ecigarette use that was can I just ask
you sorry to interrupt but I think it's
relevant here um has that increase
continued or ecigarette use AKA vaping
yeah yeah so we still see unfortunately
there there's been some improvements but
we still see way too many kids who are
using uh vaping devices early on and
part of what we did from our office is
recognizing that we actually issued the
first Federal report on ecigarettes and
youth uh we call the country's attention
to the fact that this is a crisis we
worked with members of Congress uh to
talk about the kind of action we needed
uh from a legislative and Regulatory
perspective and worked with colleagues
at the FDA and in government as well but
there are two things that are really
most important in guiding our choice
about priorities uh one is data we look
at what the numbers actually tell us
about the impact these issues are having
on the population as well as the
trajectory of Rise if something's
getting dramatically worse and people
don't realize it might be an area for us
to focus but the other critical factor
is what I hear from people on the road
so I try to spend as much time as I can
visiting communities across the country
doing Town Halls meeting with uh
community members and just trying to
frankly just listen to what's on their
mind and that's where I actually get a
lot of information as well that tell
like that's actually how I came to focus
on the issue of loneliness and isolation
it wasn't because it popped up in a
report uh as being uh the the leading
public health issue in the country it
was because everywhere I was going in
2015 whether I was talking to college
students talking to retired Americans
talking to parents in rural areas and
urban areas I kept hearing these stories
about people who felt like they were on
their own or they felt invisible or they
felt if they disappeared tomorrow no one
would even care or they felt like they
just didn't belong and it's
heartbreaking to hear that from anyone
it's particularly heartbreaking to hear
it from kids uh who you hope are
entering life and looking forward to
what comes uh but many kids weren't
feeling that
way that is very useful context and we
will get back to the isolation um crisis
um such an important initiative that
that um I just will thank you now for
having put out the the message on social
media and elsewhere um about that um
because I think one of the questions I
have in light of what you just said is
it's clear that you got your ear to the
ground you're talking to different
people um it's also critically important
that people hear from you and know um
not just what's happening but that you
perhaps want to know what uh you know
where the issues lie and what the um
what the actionable steps are that
people can take right and I think that
we now live in a hyperconnected world um
so you know in fact I'll just say that
one of the reasons I launched this
podcast is in 2020 I was going on
podcast talking about things like
maintaining sleep and circadian rhythm
and stuff from my lab related to trying
to um adjust anxiety under under
conditions where I think everyone was
anxious and sleep rhythms were disrupted
Etc um and I was somewhat surprised that
that I didn't get a warning on my phone
hey make sure you're getting morning
sunlight you know like I I'll get a
flood warning uh you know I'll get a
warning that I might get a warning but
it's only a test warning I'll get three
of those yesterday living here near the
coast but um I don't think once during
the pandemic did I get a email or a
public service announcement saying hey
you know if you are going to be indoors
a lot you're going to have to be mindful
of maintaining your circadian rhythm
because if you're not I we know based on
hundreds of studies now that drifts and
circadian rhythmicity are a precursor to
mental health issues I mean in fact
there's a new idea that many not all
suicides um are preceded by a period of
disrupted sleep which is you know kind
of makes sense in in um and it's not uh
causal of course but how come during the
pandemic we each and all as US citizens
did not get
an email or a text message saying hey
these are five things that you need to
do every day to try and stay as stable
as possible in this very uncertain
landscape that we're in well it's a
really good question and and I think
it's a it's a
reasonable and a very good suggestion to
say that hey look there should be a
clear and comprehensive way that we can
get messages out to everyone um like if
we were working in a hospital system and
there was a safety issue that came up
there would be an email sent to all the
hospital staff members saying hey this
is something you need to be aware of
right so I think it's a reasonable
expectation uh practically if you go
back though over the last 20 30 years
for on a on health issues there hasn't
been sort of an agency or an entity that
has sent emails out to everyone first of
all how to send an email out to everyone
in America is not a simple proposition
either technically it's challenging
there's some legal issues you'd have to
deal with as well but you could do a
night where you go CNN Fox NBC ABC New
York Times Wall Street like you could
hit the right the the right wi the left
wing and everything yeah that's a really
interesting suggest like one but one one
video just where they all agree like hey
this is important information so a
apolitical like no yeah so I would say
that that kind of messaging I would say
through traditional media certainly has
happened you know and it happened during
coid uh it happened for example when um
you know during the first year of coid I
was a private citizen you know in the
private private Administration but I you
know I watched both then and at the
beginning of the the Biden
Administration um many officials would
go out in front of cameras and say here
are three things you need to do to keep
yourself safe uh you know from from coid
as and that was a big question people
had how do I keep myself safe okay here
are three things you can do a couple of
challenges I would say here is that
number one even if you hit all the major
Network and cable news shows
you're still not reaching everyone right
because we're living in a in a society
where increasingly people are not
watching TV right they're getting their
news from other sources um the other
thing uh that's important to know is
that attention shifts quickly you know
in traditional media also from issue to
issue and so you might get a clip you
know out at a certain uh day or you
might get on all the Sunday shows for
example but the next day you know that
message isn't necessarily there you know
it's it's gone and people's attention
has also switched off too so there were
I mean I can count and you know we've
logged probably thousands of interviews
at this point that we've done with
mainstream media with sort of you know
concise messages about three things you
can do to protect yourself Etc and you
know I'm glad we did those we got to do
them but I think one of the things we
they don't we don't have right now in
the country and this is an I think a bit
of an Health infrastructure challenge is
we actually don't have a quick efficient
way to reach everyone in the country
with a health message just like what you
you said you know what if you wanted to
get that message about three things to
protect yourself from let's say coid or
three things to do to you know support
your health and well-being during a time
of Crisis or during a time of Health I
mean again like not just the flood
warning but the the the daily because I
I do think that most of mental and
physical health is the result of daily
practices that are you know that build
on themselves sort of like compounding
compounded Investments and then of
course there are acute challenges and
chronic challenges that people face but
things of that sort too I I I think
those kind of messages in time of Health
are are absolutely important as well and
uh you know I think I think in the sort
of I think fast-paced crisis-driven
environment that we live in uh
unfortunately people are often less are
paying less attention to those
maintenance and Improvement messages
than they are to managing the crisis
messages but I think that they're
equally as important but I do think that
what you're pointing out is an
infrastructure piece that that needs to
be built which is a way for uh you know
Health authorities to reach people you
know with information quickly and
comprehensively uh I'll just tell you
that in the 1980s when C ever coup was
Surgeon General one thing that he had
done done which was interesting is he
had actually sent a letter a physical
letter uh to all households in America
about HIV a physical letter a physical
letter some of our listeners won't know
what that is yeah so thing you read
about in the history books or something
shows up in your mailbox and you open it
and um hopefully something you want to
read this Cas this case he was worried
about HIV about the fact that people
didn't know about it so he worked
through
an with as I understand it with a member
of Congress found you know a way to do
this from a funding perspective but it
was a very unusual move uh and one that
was never replicated since and there was
never infrastructure or funding to do
that again um when I was Surge General
last time you know you know some years
ago and then this time around one of the
things I did do is I was able ble to
send a physical letter to the medical
community uh the first time it was about
the opioid use crisis and about changing
our prescribing practices in medicine so
that we expose fewer patients to the
harm of opioids while making sure people
who needed them actually got them and
the second time it was about coid
Therapeutics it was about making sure
that when we had data about medicines
that actually work like paid that we may
actually offered them to patients made
them available to patients because we
were realizing that many people weren't
getting offered life-saving medic
iations even though they were in high
risk groups um so we were able to find
you know and we had to again there two
had to sort of creatively Cobble
together resources funding this is all
sort of you know sort of behind the
scenes government stuff but the the
bottom line is in in what you want in an
emergency uh and what you want I think
in the long term is a simple clear
comprehensive way that public health
messages can get out to people and to
this day what we still have to rely on
are one traditional channels like you
know traditional media to cover the
initiatives we put out whether it's on
social media and youth mental health or
on loneliness or on youth mental health
more broadly uh we will have to rely on
online channels uh which which we do as
well or we have to look to creative
Partnerships that we build with people
who reach different audiences and then
together uh we try to get out messages
our office does all three uh of these
but uh it's a patchwork uh and and you
know and it's not always ideal but it's
what we do now I think part of what this
reflects is a broader challenge like in
government but also in society more
broadly which is that we have valued
historically prevention and health
communication very little we put the
mass majority of our resources into
treatment strategies into getting
medications to people into diagnosis and
that's very important don't get me wrong
but we are now seeing with mental health
just as one example that if we only
focus on expanding treatment and
deepening our well of knowledge there
and we don't do anything to help people
stay well that we just can't keep up
right and right because one problem
feeds the other the kids that are stay
listen I if I would grown up in today's
era I'd be on my phone and tablet late
at night because I was up reading
magazines and talking to friends on the
phone late at night right so it's not a
criticism but but you know disruptions
in sleep disruptions in circadian rhythm
disruptions lack of physical activity
poor nutrition social social isolation I
mean these are all piling the sand much
higher on this in this other side of
what you do in terms of and here I'm
obviously stating the
obvious you know so it's just going to
create a mountain of issues on the other
side which presumably has a larger
budget is what I'm sensing but doesn't
um but there's no way that budget is
large enough to deal with that I mean if
somebody's kid for instance is um trying
to address the issue of whether or not
to go on prescription
medications and or by the way folks and
or change their dietary intake because
they feel they might have ADHD for
instance I mean what are they going to
do they're going to Google they're going
to listen to podcast that they they
should be able to write first to your
organization and say you know what is
the highest level
stringency data say about these issues
and AI should be able to tell them
accurately yeah and maybe you have
somebody chime in for them I mean we all
pay taxes
I pay federal and state taxes um me too
and and and to some extent happily so
right um because it pays for public
works and and many many important things
police officers firefighters Etc but if
you don't have a channel to communicate
with people about what they and their
kids and their relatives can do
then like to some extent it feels like
it it's um it's a culde saac it's like
how how how how in the world can we get
healthy again or healthier as a as a
country the part that keeps me up at
night is and one of some of the hardest
decisions I have to make in the office
are putting aside issues that we know
deserve a lot more time and attention uh
but we just really don't have the
resources to deal with you know the
issues that we have dealt with I'm
certainly proud of my team that we
worked hard to try to raise awareness of
the issues we have taken on whether it's
around you know social media and youth
and mental health or whether around
isolation or clinical clinician burnout
or other issues like that but the truth
is that that there's more that needs to
be done more issues that need to be
tackled and we have to get to a place
where we can uh you know talk about what
I think of as the core pillars of a
healthy life right which are sleep our
nutrition our physical activity our
social relationships like these are all
vital elements to living a healthy life
right now we're not teaching kids about
this in school right but if you think
about education uh and school
as a place and a force that should PR
prep kids for the rest of their lives
they should lay a foundation for a
healthy life going forward these
absolutely are important elements for
kids to learn about I I think it's as
important for kids to learn about how to
build and maintain healthy relationships
in their life as it is frankly for them
to learn how to read and write and I
know that's a strong statement to make
but it is true in terms of its
contribution to their their happiness
their fulfillment their health and their
success yeah I I I could not agree more
uh we have a series that's out now with
a psychiatrist Paul kti about mental
health not mental illness about
self-inquiry and how to use self-inquiry
and practices that do not require uh a
therapist in order to bolster mental
mental health um of course therapists
can be very useful but not everyone has
access right and not everyone feels
comfortable doing that um but we are but
one channel I mean you are the governing
body for this um you're the Army uh Navy
and Marine so to speak of of Health as
many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012 so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but often times I
simply can't get enough servings but
with ag1 I'm sure to get enough vitamins
and minerals and the probiotics that I
need and it also contains adaptogens to
help buffer stress simply put I always
feel better when I take ag1 I have more
focus and energy and I sleep better and
it also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 to again that's
drink a1.com
huberman there's lots more to explore
there um we may have to do several uh of
these together but um to touch on all of
them but maybe we could um talk about a
few of the things that um our
listeners asked about when I solicited
for questions I got more than 10,000
responses across social media in a very
short amount of time but there was some
redundancy um one of the things that I'm
very curious can I just say on that
point though and one I'm really glad
that you asked uh folks to submit
questions and it was really excited to
see how many people actually wrote in uh
but I think it's also just a testament
to how you've done such an incredible
job building a channel to the public to
let people know about these topics that
you know that are so vital to our health
and well-being whether it's sleep or
physical activity or mental health uh
and so I just want to thank you for all
the work you're doing trying to help
people understand more about health and
clearly the fact that that folks are
engaging they're sending questions and
they're sending comments to you means
that you're building a relationship
there with a lot of folks so just kudos
to you for doing that well thank you the
the audience of the huberman Lab podcast
is is the only reason we do it I mean I
love learning and teaching but um that's
the truth so they are the podcast um the
podcast is them um so thank you for that
uh there were a lot of questions and I
also wonder about why is it
that many food
additives and preservatives and dyes and
things of that sort that are not allowed
in Europe are allowed in US Food
Products it's a really good question and
decisions around food and food safety in
particular are made by the Food and Drug
Administration so that's the FDA uh it's
not it's a separate agent independent
agency it's not one that our office uh
is involved in then sort of directing in
any way uh and so we're not involved in
those decisions and don't have insight
into how they're making their drawing
their conclusions but uh they do it in a
process just that's you know Guided by
science just like they do with
medications with devices Etc with that
said you know I am concerned
that dietary practices the food that
many Americans are consuming are in fact
not supporting their health and
well-being and in many ways are
detracting from it uh when we look at
highly processed foods one of the
concerns I have there is we often see
sodium content is very high we see the
sugar content uh is very high and you
know there are certainly additives in
there as well U that I think we I would
love to have more data on the actual
Health impacts of those but the bottom
line is that a significant portion of
our diet uh is comprised of Highly
processed foods in America and and that
worries me the AL other piece of this
that worries me are just how much you
know refined sugars are being added to
so much of our foods and most people
think that sugars are only added to
things like desserts Etc but you look at
spaghetti sauces salad dressing salad
dressings a lot of these things which we
think of as Savory products have have
sugar added to them as well and so we
are
consuming I think unhealthy levels of
sugar in our diet we're consuming a fair
amount of additives given the processed
food composition in our diet and I think
part of the reason this is happening and
I want to be very clear I don't fault
individuals out there for the
composition of their diet necessarily
because we have also made certain
decisions in our country about uh what
we subsidize about what's cheaper and
more expensive for people and the
cheapest Foods unfortunately are often
the most unhealthy Foods the most highly
processed foods uh if you are somebody
who lives in a low-income neighborhood
number of these neighborhoods don't even
have grocery stores in them which is a
you know a tragedy because you can't get
fresh produce Etc a lot of times your
shopping your grocery shopping may be
done at a local convenience store uh at
a 7-Eleven or at you know or somewhere
else that may not have like the array of
of fresh fruits and vegetables that you
and your family need I don't even think
they have vegetables I think they have
they'll occasionally have some lemons or
apples or oranges and bananas but when I
walk into a convenience store what I see
as a pharmacy I really do I see alcohol
caffeine energy drinks that have a
number of different things in them
designed to stimulate different
neuromodulators like dopamine and
serotonin I see nicotine products I see
high sugar high highly processed foods
and keep in mind I was a teenager I mean
I drank my Slurpees I had my butter
fingers you know I wasn't you know Bart
Simpson like in my lovely butter fingers
but I liked them but but it was it was a
smaller fraction of of what we ate and
when we were at home those Foods were
either not available or we weren't we
certainly weren't allowed to eat them
and um at libum you know um okay so
what's clear to me is that the FDA makes
decisions about what is safe what's not
safe but for
instance okay this last year there were
several papers published in highquality
journals showing that if people
eat just High just Sweet and Savory
Foods combined that neural in the brain
rewire through process of
neuroplasticity that drives increased
appetite and changes the response to
healthier food so that they don't taste
as as satiating okay that's sort of a
duh to a lot of people but I think it
was an important set of findings because
it said the brain actually changes in
response to the um the very uh Rich
flavorful foods that are associated with
with highly processed or even moderately
processed foods okay I mean
um that's just a couple of studies um
there was nothing in those studies that
said if you eat these Foods you're going
to develop cancer but you know at some
point one has to as a citizen a
taxpaying citizen speaking on behalf of
many other taxpaying citizens I have to
sort of take a step back and say how
long do we wait right do we have to get
a randomized clinical trial about the
you know the you know the five 100,000
sick kids that grow into sick
adults um and then run a trial where
they go on a an Elimination Diet where
they're eating only unprocessed vegan or
unprocessed meat and vegetable or
unprocessed you know starch and
vegetable but I mean I mean then we're
talking about a 30-year Health crisis
before we intervene why not I mean if I
were in charge which I'm not and clearly
I wouldn't survive in a government
organization because um well I've got
the uniform down um I always wear the
same thing but um a uniform but I
wouldn't because I would want to say
wait you know why not a on the side of
caution why not send out this AI
generated text message that tells
everybody in all the languages that
Americans speak and can understand hey
you get to make choices about what you
eat but you should be aware that um
making your diet comprised of more than
15 to 20% of these Foods is potentially
going to lead to serious issues down the
road and those serious issues are
extremely serious I mean the Obesity
crisis is really a crisis of both body
and brain metabolic challenge um that we
can talk about so you know who sets the
thresholds you know in other words why
is it that in this country we have to
wait until people start to get really
sick and dying and really struggling
before something is done in the
direction of their health and I'm not
blaming you I just want to understand
because um good question the the wealthy
people I know care a lot about their
food sources and they pay a lot of
attention to it and why aren't we
allowing everyone the opportunity to
make better choices so this is the right
question and this is something I I think
about a lot because I'm conscious about
what I eat but I also talk to folks
around the country and realize a lot of
people don't have either the information
uh or the resources to actually purchase
healthy food right and to know like
what's going to be good for them and for
their families this is why you know I
mentioned we have a list of issues that
you know we would work on you know if we
had more more more resources this is
actually one of them because to me one
of the most common questions people ask
is what should I eat
that's simple but it's it's vexing it's
complicated it's incredibly confusing if
you go online and just try to search for
information and it's a classic example
of where it's important to have an
objective
scientific Authority that can come and
then speak on Broad principles around
diet that can talk about what we know
and don't know so here's important thing
I think a lot of times people may see
something as uh you know on the market
they might read list of ingredients they
don't recognize how of them because
they're additives but they figure well
if it's there then it must have been
studied for 30 40 years and there must
be no harmful consequences right but
sometimes things are are put out there
because we have short-term data that
says that they're okay and there might
be uh but there may be a need for more
long-term data helping people understand
what do we know what do we not know is
important so that people can make
decisions for themselves based on how
much risk they want to take the other
thing that that concerns me here Andrew
is I look I I have I'll tell you I have
a bias here and my bias is that I am
worried about the you know additives and
other products we have in food that
don't have long-term data uh that's
clear in terms of health risk and so
because of that like my bias is
generally to think how can we get people
uh you know minimally or less processed
foods and how can we get them more
fruits and vegetables how can we make
sure that they have that more available
to them but we've got to not only make
the information available but we have to
make it accessible from a cost
perspective if you don't have a grocery
store in your community if vegetables
and fruits cost 3x what other foods do
that's going to be a problem right to
change diet the other thing we have to
keep in mind is that you know food
companies you know a lot of them do a
great job of actually trying to get
healthy nutritious food out to people
you know and kudos to them but I worry
also that there's an incentive also to
just try to sell more and more and more
of your product and one of the ways to
do that is to try to hack uh the body to
kind of figure out okay well what kind
of synthetic additives could I put
together here or what kind of uh
combination of nutrients could I put
together that will get people coming
back for more and more and more and we
saw this in the nicotine industry you
saw the Nick industry you also I would
say another parallels you see it in
social media as well where the business
model of the social media platforms is
built on volume of use right how much
time am I spending on the platforms it's
not quality of time it's quantity of
time right so if that's the business
model then you're going to design your
platform to Max maximize how much time
someone spends on them regardless of
whether it's detracting from sleep
detracting from inperson interaction
detracting from anything else it's
healthy regardless of whether that may
be causing certain harms right like the
business model dictates you know in many
ways how these things are designed and
that applies I think to food as well so
which is why I think it's incumbent upon
us to be particularly cautious uh with
highly processed foods foods that foods
that have additives and to understand
how is this impacting our brain how is
that impacting our satiety
how is it um leading potentially to
Greater ingestion that is healthy and
leading to things like obesity which
have a whole host of other medical
conditions from cancer to arthritis to
diabetes and heart disease associated
with it those are the questions as a as
a citizen as a father of two young kids
who's trying to bring them up at with a
healthy lifestyle those are the
questions that I would want to know the
answers to and it's one of the reasons I
think these kind of objective reports
are so important for the
public I'm starting to see the the scope
of the problem and the mechanics
involved in trying to alleviate these
issues are complex I I I I see that they
are also one other thing that is
important to do that so is you need to
have
authorities that can speak to these
issues that are insulated from political
retribution right so and to explain this
like Amen to that yeah I mean listen as
somebody forgive me for interrupting but
somebody who from time to time will um
make not recommendations but we'll offer
information about potential actionable
items you know things that people could
do or not do according to a couple of
studies that come have come out I mean
have come under intense scrutiny from my
colleagues um who are like wait that's
not a randomized control trial how can
you do that and yet I know from being in
this field for a long time that for
instance the emerging therapies for for
PTSD and depression that are now based
on federal funding for things like um
and I'm not recommending this by the way
for children or for everybody but for
instance the um macro do psilocybin
therapeutically supported uh legal use
of psilocybin for for uh major
depression the data there are they're
not perfect but they're pretty darn good
compared to the major
ssris um but for years if if an academic
said the the words I just said they'd
lose their job almost instantaneously
because they're Controlled Substances um
that's a that's a Todo but then there
are a number of things that we're
talking about here that are just about
making better choices about things to
avoid right if people understood I think
that um is sugar poison well some of my
audience will say sugar is poison it's
as addictive as cocaine look it is not
as addictive as cocaine or heroin it is
not however if a child or adult is
eating very sweet or very Savory Foods
of any kind consistently if those are
not um healthy foods or if they are if
they contain unhealthy additives over
time the brain will rewire so that
healthy foods don't taste is good they
won't be the choices that people make
and you're going to end up with a sick
individual period And I don't think we
need one more clinical trial funded by
federal tax dollars to support that
statement what I'm starting to gather is
that you're a very rational grounded
broad thinkinking individual I'm not
just saying that because you're sitting
here and you're trained in medicine and
you understand the science uh but that
you don't have the means at your
disposal to put out a call that says hey
folks having some sugar every once in a
while treating the kids to ice cream
great but if 80% or more of the diet it
of our kids isn't made up of minimally
or non-processed Foods their brains are
going to be rewired in unhealthy ways
and you can almost expect that they're
going to have some Health Challenge in
the future that may not be um you know
autism or schizophrenia but is going to
be a major Health Challenge of a and
that is serious and Now's the Time to
intervene by avoiding certain things and
if you don't want to do it look it's a
free country at that level you're
welcome to do it but you'd be better off
spending X number of dollars on these
healthier foods yeah because there's
also and we know this from my colleague
Ali crum's laboratory at Stanford that
even the mere knowledge that certain
foods are nutritious can lead to more
satiety from eating those Foods at the
level of hormone release not just
psychologically you're telling yourself
the Orange is as tasty and and filling
as a candy bar but the understanding of
of the fact that it is nutritious
actually leads to shifts in patterns of
of you know grillin secretion Etc that
that change so people can be feel better
on a healthier slightly lower calorie
nutrient enrich diet of healthy proteins
and fruits and vegetables and it's not a
mind trick it's it's physiology anyway I
I I think um I I feel your pain frankly
and I'll tell you look sometimes people
ask hey why don't you just go out and
say a couple of statements that you just
said would that be fine like why why is
time needed to prep something like that
why are resources needed Etc here's
actually why like I know in today's day
and age it's easy to just go and like
rattle off off you know off the cff
statements or shoot from the Welcome on
my social media channels anytime and
really to get the word out to millions
of people I appreciate that and I may
take you up on that but I'll tell you
that one of the reason one of the things
we always do recognizing that when we
put out statements that people people
one they they trust it's coming from a
scientific Authority and that it's been
vetted right so we put the effort and
time into vetting this thoroughly we
check sources we look at the data we
talk to experts we think about how to
communicate this in the right way that's
the work the behind the scenes work sure
uh that we do before we put out sort of
reports and and initiatives because we
want people to have confidence you know
in in what they're hearing we also know
that when we put out initiatives that
other people build on them
philanthropists you know and and
foundations will then think about should
I fund work in this area uh you know
schools and workplaces will think about
shifting some of their practice policy
makers will also think about legislation
uh that they may uh want to design based
on that so we want to make sure it it's
really solid but the point I was making
when I said also that we have to make
sure that not just our office but folks
who are you know in public health and
who are in medicine who are trying to
speak to the public about their health
that they're protected from retribution
and taxes this is what I meant which is
that saying things about diet saying
things about
tobacco these can be challenging for
some folks because there are Industries
built around these right which may not
always like what you have to say uh if
it hurts their business model or their
bottom line and they may then lean on um
political leaders elected leaders others
to then try to silence you or or shut
you up and I'll tell you I've
experienced this in the past you know
when I was Surgeon General during my
first term I had issued two uh key
reports one was on alcohol drugs and
health about the addiction crisis uh and
the other was about the ecigarette
crisis among youth I will tell you that
there were plenty of people who were
very unhappy that I was issuing the
First Federal report on ecigarettes um
folks who felt that hey um this is going
to make folks unhappy it's going to
create political pressure uh it's going
to create a lot of problems uh similarly
with alcohol drugs and health there are
many folks who said hey if you do this
you're really going to upset the AL alol
industry do you really need to have
alcohol in the report why don't you just
focus on other drugs um why don't you
take alcohol out of the title you know
all of these sort of you know concerns
telling you this who so these are people
who get paid by the alcohol industry no
these are people in government who are
reading the te leaves and who who are
supportive of the work we're doing but
are saying hey like you're going to
really upset a lot of people in industry
and you're also going to help a lot of
people yeah well this is what it comes
down to they say well and if you upset
folks then they're going to try to fire
you they're going to try to do all these
things to which honestly like my my
response to a lot of these and the
reason we just put them out anyway was
because I said well the worst thing that
can happen is I get fired and that's
okay you know if I if I go out knowing I
did the right thing here then I'm fine
with that I'm not looking to build a
lifelong career in government I'm not
doing this job to like you know get to
the next thing on the ladder like this
is about serving for the time I can I
want to be able to go to sleep at night
look myself in the mirror and know I did
so with Integrity um so that was an easy
decision for me but but my point is that
like we have to be thoughtful that in
these issues that there are going to be
headwinds right I'm sure in your case
for example you've probably gotten push
back from folks about talking about
certain things that may have rankled
folks who may have had an interest in
those issues and that's okay you keep
talking about them as as you should and
I'm grateful for that um but this is
especially important at a time where I
think public trust in our institutions
more broadly and in science and in
medicine medicine have taken a hit over
the last few years and I think it's a
time where we have to be even more
Vigilant those of us in medicine and
public health to make sure that what we
do is based on data that we're
transparent about why we're saying what
we're saying that we're also clear about
what we know and what we don't know so
that if recommendations change over time
people recognize that this isn't
necessarily flip-flopping you should
change your recommendations if the data
changes uh if the circumstances change
so uh anyway this is all part of the
work that we've got to do but to me this
is a really important part of the work
the Integrity behind our work in public
health is not just about the issue we're
taking on today it's about the trust
that we need to rebuild uh in the field
more
broadly so if I understand
correctly if you were to for instance uh
put out a call that says look you know
there are food additives that are
allowed in the US that are not allowed
in Europe that may be of risk we don't
have enough data at present to say to
avoid these things but here's a kind of
a yellow zone you know you Green known
to be safe red clearly known to be
unsafe yellow we just don't know yet not
enough data um so here's what my
recommendation would be for my children
yeah it's free country you know um there
are people that argue it's not but at
least at the level of which foods you
want to buy with your own budget um it's
it's a free country so you're saying
that um you get messages that warnings
about certain things could lead to push
back but if I have to imagine that
there's something and I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but there has to be
either the people that are saying look
there could be problems are just
friction averse they're just don't like
anyone to be angry at anyone or um there
there must be some incentive for things
to remain quiet I mean I mean certainly
the government has not had problems
saying uh to do things or to not do
things that had uh that upset companies
or shut down companies or or elevated
companies and their success so I I'm
conf I'd like to know more about the
back Contour of this well look I think
and this is not too dissimilar for I
think what happens in in other
Industries but it's you know whenever
you you do something in whether it's in
the private sector or in government
people we what what are the pros cons
what's the push back I'm going to get
how do I deal with that push back right
uh and push back isn't always a bad
thing right if you get push back from
the public people hey that doesn't make
sense to makees that's you should listen
to that and and use it to inform your
approach but that's the public whose
your job is to serve I'm talking about
push back from companies is is different
right so when push back comes from
people who have a financial interest uh
in the product that you may be
commenting on then you you've got to be
you need to know about that number one
so that you know how to how to mitigate
it and while people may take different
approaches to this my Approach as a
public official as Surgeon General has
been to say at the end of the day like
I'm happy to to hear from anyone and in
terms of their concerns or push back but
at the end of the day what's going to
guide my decisions about what we issues
we take on what decisions we make and
what we say to the public is going to be
what is in driven by science in the
public interest and if that means it's
politically inconvenient that's okay if
that means that you know something
happens you know to my job that's okay
too you know like we look the bottom
line is life is short we don't know how
much time we have here we may as well
make the time we have count we as to do
the things uh that are right and that
are going to serve people that's my
simple philosophy my parents taught me
when I was growing up so that's the
approach I I bring to this and that's
why if we were to do let's say an
initiative on diet I have no doubt that
some of the things that we would say
would be perturbing uh to folks who had
a financial interest in the industry
because I don't think that the current
setup in the industry is serving the
public well uh I I think we have made
unhealthy Foods cheap that's a problem
we've made healthy foods expensive
that's a problem we put Health from a
dietary perspective Out Of Reach for
millions of Americans that is a
fundamental problem and we've also
disempowered people with by not giving
them the information that they need to
make decisions so even if you have
resources I guarantee there are people
listening to this podcast and many more
people out there who go to the grocery
store and just feel confused like what
on Earth should I buy what's healthy
what's okay anymore um it's just hard to
know and so I think we've done a
disservice by not doing more to help the
public understand and access healthy
foods and again it's why it's an issue
that
you know that that was on our list of
issues that we would want to work on
because I think that the public health
need here is is
immense I'd like to just take a brief
break and thank one of our sponsors
which is element element is an
electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means plenty of salt sodium magnesium
and potassium the so-called electrolytes
and no sugar now salt magnesium and
potassium are critical to the function
of all the cells in your body in
particular to the function of your nerve
cells also called neurons now people of
course have varying levels of
requirements for sodium so people with
hypertension or prehypertension probably
shouldn't increase their sodium however
many people are surprised to find that
by increasing their sodium intake they
are able to function better cognitively
and physically and that's because a lot
of people especially people who are
following low carbohydrate or even
moderate carbohydrate and really clean
diets often times they're excreting a
lot of water and electrolytes along with
it and simply by increasing their
electrolyte intake using element they
just feel better and function better I
typically drink element first thing in
the morning when I wake up in order to
hydrate my body and make sure I have
enough electrolytes and while I do any
kind of physical training and certainly
I drink element in my water when I'm in
the sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's LM
nt.com huberman to claim a free element
sample pack with your purchase again
that's drink element LM nt.com
huberman I have a question about trust
in big institutions and public health
initiatives in general um the question
is about masks um early in the pandemic
as I recall we were told that masks were
not necessary then we were told they are
necessary and I think for a lot of
people that flip in messaging um landed
like a parent telling their teenage kid
to always wear a seat belt but then you
look into the front seat and Mom and Dad
aren't wearing seat belts and as anyone
who's been around teenagers there has
been one you make that mistake once
you're not making it again and you may
never recover from that particular
example in other words the public felt
like there was a switch of messaging but
what I don't recall happening was a like
a hey we got that one wrong so sorry on
us MH you know what the new data say
blank what I recall was a message of
don't and then do but there wasn't a lot
of um kind of acknowledgment of of how
challenging the situation was it was
just a lot of top down
mandates and in my opinion and this is
just my opinion I think that led to a
pretty rapid distrust of subsequent
messages from which we still haven't
really recovered um and
so why do you think it's so challenging
for public facing officials to just say
look doing the best we can at the moment
screwed up
before changing the message now may
change again we're navigating this in in
real time it's Dynamic yeah please stay
with us because you know goes without
saying there's been a huge Chasm around
this and related issues yeah look this
it's an important question and look I
I'm always I want to be thoughtful about
um you know how I comment on what was
done in the first year of the pandemic I
was I was a citizen I was outside
government and I don't know what was
happening inside government in terms of
the the decisions that were made made
there but I do know sometimes from my
experience in Ebola and in zika during
those uh experiences we had as a country
that in the you know in the fog of War
when everything's coming at you
sometimes it's hard to make the right
decision all the time right so I I want
to give some of those folks who were
there uh you know in the first year of
the pandemic you know some benefit of
the doubt but I do think that the
important thing uh the principle I I
certainly try to follow but one I think
that uh and you know we can all do
better I Can Do Better certainly too uh
but I think an important principle for
us in public health communication has to
be that we're
clear that we're transparent about what
we know and what we don't know uh and
that we explain the why to people so if
we're telling someone to do something
why is it because there's a lot of data
behind it is it because it's a sort of
expert agreement best practice because
sometimes as you know in in medicine
sometimes when we don't have enough data
to guide us on on a therapeutic approach
but when the problem is imminent then
sometimes experts will get together and
put together expert inform formed
guidelines to say okay look based on our
best judgment and the limited data we
have here's what we would recommend and
as the data evolves we will change you
know and and modify those
recommendations we do that with
hypertension right you evolve and update
recommendations we do that with lipids
um here too I think that has to be like
a key part of the approach I think one
of the challenges that I saw many public
health officials encounter was even when
they went out with Comprehensive
messages like that uh which are hard to
fit into a sound bite or into simple
posts on social media um often a lot of
that wasn't covered what gets covered is
the Top Line you know this is what's
being recommended that's what's being
required Etc all the explanation is lost
it's missing right and I think we also
are living in a time where people are
reading headlines like they're living
busy lives right they're not
necessarily you know always hearing all
of the Nuance you know that's being
explained um but I think that that's a
challenge right is like I know many
public officials struggled with how do
you deliver nuanced information uh at a
time when there isn't a clear black and
white answer to things but I think the
last piece around this is um I think
something I was taught early in medical
school is to approach your patients with
humility recognizing that even though
you have more training than they do uh
you don't aren't living their life you
don't necessarily know what they're
going through and you shouldn't assume
um things about them right and so
approaching with humility means that um
you've got to recognize that not
everyone's going to be able to follow
your guidance and if they aren't able to
that doesn't mean you criticize them it
also means recognizing that people may
have ideas or suggestions for you that
may actually improve your
recommendations or how you communicate
and so I these are the principles I
think that are important in public
communication but I think that both the
challenge of translating nuanced
arguments into what's actually covered
that was tough for many public health
officials I think the other thing
honestly just on a human level that
became hard for many of them and I I'm
thinking particularly about local and
state public health officials who are on
the front lines that I talked to a lot
was they ended up getting attacked a lot
and abused a lot during the pandemic and
I don't just mean like attacked online I
mean people showing up at their houses
people harassing their children uh
people threatening their safety um and
and this was often people who were upset
about some of the requirements that were
being put down from local Departments of
health and you can understand Co was as
stressful a time as we've seen recently
people lost their jobs people were
losing loved ones I mean talk about a
stressful time but I think at a human
level Public Health officials who were
exposed to that kind of abuse and who
started to worry about their children's
safety um many of them stepped out of
the arena and said is this really worth
it to put my family at risk um and that
was hard because we lost a lot of good
Public Health people in that respect so
I think I think in addition to having
sort of these core principles of public
health communication in place I think
what we also need to restore is an
environment where we of frankly of
humility and civility where where we
don't attack people you know who maybe
have different views or are coming out
with recommendations that um you know
are not palatable uh to us and uh and I
think it's also incumbent upon our
leaders in society to not Stoke that
kind of resentment and violence as well
CU that happened during the pandemic as
Co got increasingly politicized and you
know while that may have been at times
done for political reasons here or there
the people who suffered were both the
public health leaders who were trying to
do the right thing for their communities
and the public themselves who weren't
able to have a clear direct channel uh
to and a dialogue with their Public
Health officials uh because a lot of
that ended up getting closed off yeah I
feel like there was a lot of talking
down to the dissenters in the general
public yeah uh and I totally agree that
um you know getting violent or harassing
people with whom you disagree is is
totally inappropriate Andrew the one
thing just to say about the humility
piece and I'll give you an example here
of where I think this could have and
should have been done better is it an
effort for example around masks uh to
recommend that people wear masks and one
important thing just to know is that
when it comes to like schools requiring
masks like those are decisions that are
made on local levels right the federal
government doesn't mandate masks in
schools uh doesn't have the authority to
do that so those are local local
decisions but at the end of the day
there were people who did not want their
children to wear masks right for a
variety of reasons uh some worried about
their develop Social Development some
worried that it was adding stress to
their kids like people had met different
reasons why they may or may not have
wanted their children to wear masks and
one of the things I think that was not
helpful was that when there were parents
who made the decision they didn't want
their kids to wear masks um I think some
of them received a lot of critic iism uh
without people necessarily stopping to
understand why they may have been making
that decision because I'll say as a
parent whose children were in school you
know my kids are five and seven and um
in the first year of the pandemic they
were doing preschool virtually which was
a nightmare it was incredibly hard for
us even when they got back to school in
the fall of 2021 um it was a really
tough like adjustment for them and I
could understand like some of the
concerns that parents uh were having
wondering about hey how are these
precautions affecting my child's
experience and Social Development so on
the whole this the recommendation may
still be uh Hey improve ventilation your
classrooms recommend masking recommend
testing Etc but those recommendations I
think have to be made in a way that
acknowledges like the humanity of people
who are may have a different point of
view or may make a different decision uh
for their child and I know that when loc
localities made the decision in many
cases to require uh schools in their you
know kids in their District to wear a
mask that put some parents who didn't
want that they put them in a hard place
right and but I think that our failure
to actually have an open honest
respectful conversation about this where
we didn't feel like we were uh each
being attacked you know as parents for
our decisions or as community members
for the decisions we were making I think
that not only hindered I think the
response but I think it actually
contributed to this division the sense
of black and whiteness that hey it's us
against them and then suddenly if I was
against one measure then I was against
all of them you know or if I was for one
measure I was for all of them because we
just started segregating into sites uh
and this became a polarized uh you know
experience at a time where really it
should have been a crisis that brought
us together as messy as it was um and
that honestly Andrew is what I worry
about most for the next pandemic right
like I think we've learned a lot from
this pandemic about uh how to
manufacture vaccines and de and how to
develop them quickly uh how to
distribute them uh efficiently uh and
you know we had one one was one of the I
think most historic and and effective
vaccine distribution efforts in this
country even though certainly could have
been better but it was historic by by
all measures um we've learned a lot
about how to do vaccines Therapeutics uh
a lot of the nuts and bolts of a
pandemic response well but I worry what
we are still struggling with is how we
build trust how we communicate with the
public and how we stay together as a
country in the face of adversity because
if we're going to if we're divided the
way we were during coid during the next
pandemic or the next you know for a
threat that may come from a foreign
adversary that's a huge national
security issue for us and so that that's
what keeps me up at night when I think
about the next pandemic that may come
two questions relate to what you just
said first of all um as it relates to
vaccines in my opinion um and I think
the opinion of many people out there
that the response to the next pandemic
um will be heavily contingent
on at least some sort of acknowledgment
that there are people who at least feel
that there have been vaccine injuries
right to Simply say um okay the previous
time round with coid went this way and
now there's now virus X right let's hope
not God forbid but sounds like it's
coming at some point and people are
going to think to the last time and
they're going
to immediately say well the last time we
were told to you know uh take a vaccine
some people had a good experience with
that other people didn't and it in this
empathy model of acknowledging and you
know you know letting your moral compass
guide and understanding the why behind
what people are are are doing and how
they're reacting it seems to me that now
would be the time to at least try and
understand where they're coming from
even if one disagrees maybe even
especially if one disagrees and try and
get people aligned now before the next
pandemic it and um so what efforts are
being made if any to try and acknowledge
um that some people really do feel as if
they were harmed I'm not saying if they
were or not but clearly there are people
who feel that they were people they know
were harmed is there an effort to
present them with data to have
discussions with them to try and get
people aligned so that the next time
around uh we can be more of a unified
front whatever the necessary response
happens to be yeah no it's a really
important question and and to me I
always go back to sort of first
principles from practicing medicine
right which is if there is a medicine
you give a patient and even if it helps
99.99% of patients but this one
particular patient happen to be harmed
by it you go in you acknowledge it you
talk about it and you together TR out a
path for how you want to move forward
and the path forward might be yes let's
get rid of that medication but let's use
an alternative let's try it or we can't
use that medication anymore here are the
risks you may sustain but we'll find
other ways to protect you right so
that's what we would do in medicine
right that's what I've done with
patients over the years I think here too
similarly when I think when it comes to
tracking Adverse Events from vaccines
this is an area where the CDC and the
FDA track and collaborate uh and
tracking means not just not only
collecting reports from the public and
from clinicians when they see uh an
effect that may be related to a vaccine
but it also involves analyzing those to
see were they correlated or were there's
actual causation there right because um
you know if I if today for example uh I
felt unwell uh and I trace back what
happened yesterday and it turns out hey
I ate this burrito that was out in the
the Sun for way too long um the question
is am I feeling sick because the burrito
or did the burrito just happen to be you
know a you know something that happened
but it's independent of how I'm feeling
um maybe it turns out somebody was
actually sick uh with a GI bug you know
around me and that's the reason uh that
I'm feeling the way I am today so the
analysis that needs to be done on cases
that are reported uh is important and
it's something that the CDC and the FDA
do together now that analysis I think is
essential to communicate clearly to the
public um and whenever I engage with
folks in the public which we do often
and people will talk to me about their
experiences with vaccines I do think
it's important to acknowledge what
people have gone through um like some
people for example like when I got uh
vaccinated for Co for example I I felt
like I had mild flu like symptoms for a
couple of days you know it wasn't great
I would have preferred I didn't you know
have those feelings like you know and uh
then I felt better a couple of days
later and then I moved on but you know I
acknowledge it didn't feel good you know
to to feel that way there are other
people who may have had U experiences
where they felt that they had more
serious uh you know side effects and
there may be a question was that related
to the vaccine or not so I think we have
to both hear and acknowledge those I
certainly try to do that I know I think
it's important to keep doing that across
all of government but I also think it's
important for us to to help people
understand the process that we have to
go through to understand whether those
are related or not if you go online and
the cdc's uh site where they collect a
lot of this information and you just
purely look at reports that are given of
potential adverse effects
that you can't sort of take that and say
ah those are all related to the vaccine
look at this rate of harm it's
extraordinarily High because we don't
actually do that with any other vaccine
or medicine right sure we we start there
we do the analysis and we try to
understand what's actually related or
not so I think that's that's what we've
got to do here too one last thing I'll
say is that it's important I think also
for us to to help put this in context of
other vaccines and medicines and
interventions that we use so for example
just take Tylenol for example like most
people think oh well Tylenol it's safe
there's nothing bad happens if you take
Tylenol Etc but people who track the
data know that Tylenol by and large is a
generally speaking a safe medication but
there are people who experience adverse
effects from Tylenol liver damage you
know and and other adverse effects uh
and you know that data is available but
what has happened in the case of that
medication is that the risks and
benefits are both analyzed and then a
recommendation is put forward about a
generally safe way to use it and then
there's data put out about the the side
effects common or rare right but I think
sometimes we also forget that a lot of
the medicines that we have come to take
and just see as normal part of our life
just like any other vaccine like there's
some rate of rare side effects that will
happen I say that because what I worry
about in the black and white environment
that we're living in is sometimes people
will take an anecdote about a potential
adverse effect and we'll portray that as
the rule right and we'll say well look I
know somebody who had this side effect
so nobody should take this because this
is what's going to happen to you if we
did that nobody would ever take Tylenol
no one would ever take Ibuprofen no one
would take NyQuil like no one would take
any of the common medications that we
pick up at the drugstore and that we
commonly use so uh that's how I think we
have to approach this with a combination
of of clear communication empathic
listening and and data and cont text um
again that doesn't fit neatly in a in a
in a social media post per se but I
think part of what we're we need to do
as a country is rebuild the relationship
honestly between the medical and public
health establishment and the public and
I think it's starts with this kind of
communication uh the other question I
had about the next pandemic and the one
we just had is uh why not have
Committees of people of diverse
backgrounds socioeconomic diversity
racial diversity
uh every aspect of diversity rather than
individuals standing there telling us
what to do for several reasons one is um
we are a country of many different
people yeah I think we um there are
dozens if not hundreds of scientific
papers showing that patients follow the
advice of doctors that look like them
and sound like them or to whom they
would aspire to be like yeah we know
this and yet Public Health officials
typically are unitary one person telling
us do this don't do that this is a good
idea that's a bad idea I I'm but one
citizen but I'm putting up both hands
both feet and all toes and saying that
committees small but diverse committees
that people can relate to and feel as if
um the messages that they're getting are
vetted through a common understanding
yeah so it's a really good suggestion
and and I could agree with you more that
A diversity of voices is really
important to to get a message out out
and during Co actually that's one of the
things that our office actually was was
helping to build was something called
the community core right where we
actually we recognize so very clearly
this is something I you know I came to
see as a doctor sometimes I was the
right person to message to a patient
sometimes I wasn't right sometimes it
was the nurse sometimes it was uh the
medical student sometimes it was an
administrator or the the social worker
with different background different life
experiences so part of this work is
knowing when to step up when to step
back right but the community Corp that
we were building was a really diverse uh
you know group of people um and a lot of
them had Public Health backgrounds but a
lot of them were Community leaders who
understood Health even though they
didn't have formal training um but
they're people who knew their
communities right and they had the trust
of their communities and they understood
what was going on they wanted to be
helpful so we brought them together to
say okay look here's what the science is
telling us here the general
recommendations um here's what we would
provide uh you ask us any questions you
have like if there's something we don't
know we'll go back and look it up um but
you're the leaders in your community
they should be hearing from you you know
about about these messages and then that
those folks went out and actually we
worked closely with them collaborated
with them uh they would design the
messages for their community based on
what they thought made sense they
weren't taking what we said word for
word and we didn't want them to um but
to me like that kind of diverse approach
is what we need more of now you know
I'll tell you what I would I would have
liked I would have liked if more media
networks put those folks on TV and got
them on the radio right because it's
important that many of them were showing
up in their communities were knocking on
doors were uh doing local you know
podcasts Etc and that was great but I
would have liked more of their faces I
carried on TV right so that's a place
where when when we talk to media and
when I talk to folks in media one of the
things I encourage them and push them to
do also is to say look if you can take
more of these diverse faces and voices
and put them out there that's actually
good for the community and it also helps
people see that it's not like one or two
people who are sort of pushing an agenda
here this is like the Public Health
Community is Big it's broad it's diverse
it has a lot of voices and and as the
more voices we can hear from as public I
think the better off we are yeah here
here I I you know again I
genuinely hope and pray that we don't
have another pandemic but if and when we
do I hope there will be committees
rather than individuals I know we you
know this is a thing in this country we
like the idea that one person's going to
save the climate one person's going to
save transportation one person you know
the covers the person of the year type
approach um but we but then we get
frustrated when that person does things
or makes decisions that we don't like in
their public or personal life and then
it all seems to fall into Division and I
just feel like we not talking about
groups of hundreds of people but small
groups so I think we're aligned in that
way yeah and and look there there's I
think a notion that um I think sometimes
we do want like the one person who can
not only necessarily have all our trust
and we can look to but also who we can
hold accountable you know if something
uh doesn't quite work out if we don't
like something um and and while I get
that sort of mentality I think that in
this moment especially when we're trying
to rebuild trust I think it's important
for people to know that what they may be
hearing in terms of medical or SC Public
Health recommendations it's important
for them to know how broad an audience
that's coming from or broad a group of
experts right and we there was a lot
more broad agreement for example during
coid and uh during Ebola during zika on
Public Health recommendations but you
wouldn't always know it if you turn on
the TV because you were seeing the same
couple of faces so I think we have to to
certainly diversify that um one other
thing I think I'll tell you that's
important here is I think we have to
also think about how we fund groups on
the ground that are doing the the hard
work of getting Public Health messages
out because one of the things that those
groups often would tell me and these are
I might say the groups I'm I'm talking
about the community organization that
spent years in a neighborhood getting to
know families where folks recognize them
when they're walking down the street
they're like oh yeah that's a person
from organization X they understand us
they get us they're looking out for us a
lot of those organizations had spent
their resources helping the community
getting to know the community but they
didn't have sophisticated mechanisms to
apply for grants for example they didn't
have grant writers who had done this a
thousand times so
historically those groups have a hard
time getting support and funding so I'll
tell you one interesting thing my my
wife did which I certainly was very of
is she was helping to to build an effort
and to build a nonprofit organization
with a couple of colleagues that
organization of people who knew how to
get money how to apply for Grants how to
get Foundation support but who also had
the wisdom to know that the most
important they could do was to give
portions of that money to groups on the
ground so they saw themselves as an
organization that channeled money to
groups that had trust and they executed
their their their mission that way and
that was very effective and I think we
need more of that when it comes to
disseminating funding one thing I think
many people may not uh may or may not
appreciate is that when you it's
actually hard from government to put out
a lot of money uh at once and to do so
quickly right um like when you've got a
lot of funds that you need to get into
communities what happens is the federal
government often will give it to States
states will then give it to local
communities uh to like the local
Department of Public Health part
potentially and then they will look to
distribute it to others that takes time
but also means if you're not connected
to that network if you don't know your
local Department of Health or you're not
connected to the State Department of
Health sometimes it can be challenging
to figure out how to get the money and
so I think we need more operations like
you know like what my wife and others
have been building to try to get those
funds directly to the folks who not you
don't necessarily have the most fancy
you know grant writing operation but
they have their relationships because at
the end of the day it's those
relationships that create the trust it's
a trust that allows in life-saving
information
to get to people and that's the link
that's missing very
interesting Pharma big Pharma I got a
lot of questions
about whether or not big Pharma is on
the take for every Public Health
Initiative now as uh somebody
who understands a bit about and
certainly believes in the use of certain
prescription medications I find most um
questions about quote unquote big Pharma
to overlook fact that there are
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of medications that save lives and
enrich people's lives that are
prescription drugs um I also believe my
audience knows I say it over and over
again that Better Living Through
Chemistry still requires Better Living
we still have to get our sunlight get
our sleep social connection good
nutrition exercise and all those things
there's just no pill that's going to
replace those yeah okay but I think it's
a valid question that people are
asking is there a direct relationship
between between big Pharma and public
health initiatives in a way that should
have us concerned about the messaging
that we're getting and at times and the
fact that the United States consumes the
vast majority of drugs for mental health
for instance as compared to other
countries so that's one question and
then um I want to dovetail into that
question what are your thoughts on the
fact that you know there's a history of
say the tobacco industry being you know
uh very uh interdigitated shall we say
with um government policies in ways that
had us basically injure if not kill
millions of Americans and then
eventually say you can't smoke on near a
hospital you can't smoke anywhere
there's very few places where you can
consume tobacco products you know that
that kind of um relationship and
financial incentives and then a lot of
backpedaling later um I think wore on
people's um trust MH so how should we
frame the relationship
between the pharmaceutical industry
government and public health initiatives
in a way that is you know at least
halfway functional it look I I
understand where the concern and
suspicion comes from right and look I I
think it's important that public health
initiatives and medical advice is
independent of the influence of
industries that may seek to profit uh
from what's being recommended or from
medications that are being prescribed
and we look we have a history in
medicine right of doctors who were you
know given gifts and vacations and all
kinds of fancy things by Pharma
companies in an effort to influence what
they prescribed that was really
problematic and now we're seeing a lot
less of that which is good a lot of
rules are being put in place by medical
societies and professional societies and
by academic institutions to say this is
an unacceptable way to practice and
that's really important because I do
think that human psychology is that
sometimes we underestimate how much
we're influenced by incentives we think
ah yeah I'm getting that but I know how
to make independent decisions but at the
end of the day we're human and and we
influenced or it's a great drug it could
be wow this is a drug that's really
helping my patients I'm happy to
recommend it to them yeah so the this so
I want to separate one thing though like
taking money from Pharma companies as a
physician I think is highly problematic
right I think it's hard to say that it
doesn't influence practice maybe it
doesn't for some people but it's just
it's really hard to know who those
people are um I do think that separate
from that you can be a physician who
prescribes medications because you
believe they work look as a doctor I
have prescribed many antibiotics during
cases of infection that have helped my
patients and I would prescribe those
again I am glad that those exist um in
many cases they've saved the lives you
know of patients I was caring for in the
hospital so that's what what should
drive us is is does the data show that
they work and does our patient need them
right that's what should drive our
decisions when it comes to Public Health
recommendations here too I think a
similar principle holds which is that I
don't think that Pharma money uh should
be influencing our Public Health
decisions which means that it shouldn't
be funding our public health
organizations that are making
recommendations certainly I'll you know
I know this is obvious to you but I'll
say just to be clear for everyone who's
listening like our office uh doesn't
take any money from industry not just
Pharma industry from any industry like
our the money that we get is allocated
by Congress at the end of the day it's
taxpayer money and that's all we get and
and that's important we don't want money
from the you know from pharmaceutical
companies um but that's important
because people need to know that these
decisions are not being made for for
financial gain um with that being said I
there's a broader concern I have Andrew
which is I think that we have become a
pill for every problem Society where we
look for a quick fix of a medicine for
every challenge uh that we may incur and
sometimes yes I'm I'm a believer that if
science you know helps us create uh
medications that can help solve disease
we should use them appropriately but I
think we discount heavily the behavioral
changes that we need to make the more
broader societal and environmental
changes that we need to make that
influence our health like our food
environment matters for our health our
decisions about
how Physically Active we are matter for
our health whether or not we sleep
matters for our health and all of these
impact our mental health and well-being
as well and so I I when when I think
about the that bias that that to me is
not always you know stemming from money
that came from a pharmaceutical company
although I think it the ads that we see
all the time uh from Pharma companies I
think try to convince us that hey just
take this pill once a day and all your
problems will go away but I think it's
more complex than that and and I think
that even for you know in the health
care setting like if you're uh if you're
seeing a patient who has pain uh who's
having intense pain it feels easier
sometimes to prescribe a medication for
that pain rather than trying to to deal
with non-medication based you know
approaches or try to get the deeper
origins of the pain I'm not saying
that's what doctors do all the time but
I'm saying that we're living in an
environment and a broader culture where
we I think increase ly reach for
something that we see as a quick
immediate fix uh and again don't blame
people for that we rather take a quick
fix over something that's going to take
a long time but I think it is selling us
I think sometimes a false hope which is
that that's all we need to solve our
problems and I think a lot of times you
need more you need the behavioral
changes you need the environmental
changes um that's one of my big concerns
in terms of how we communicate about
health would a potential solution be
this idea of small committees so let's
say uh somebody is experiencing chronic
pain localized or general that they
would go to their general practitioner
but in the room would also be somebody
who understands sematic medicine uh a
trained clinical psychologists who
understand sematics that the body and
the brain are linked through the nervous
system um and could also assess um you
know possible psychological Roots uh of
the issue and then somebody in the room
who can make um Behavior
nutritional um maybe even
supplementation based safe
supplementation based recommendations
and then the physician who can say you
know and in addition to that I think the
person should have on hand you know a 5
milligram dosage of a prescription drug
that if they need it they could take and
I think it would provide a lot of
protections against you know uh
potential adverse effects of any one of
those things in isolation um there are
great Protections in having people meet
in groups um for lots of reasons and the
person would feel very well cared for um
so again small Committees of people with
diverse expertise pooling together to
treat people from a for lack of a better
word a more holistic perspective why not
I mean you're describing the dream I
think that's exactly what we need
interdisciplinary teams that can provide
integrative care recognizing that in
this day and age there's not one person
who has all the expertise to help us
figure out how to best manage our health
challenges
um I think what we have not figured out
are a couple of things number one who
are all the right people who need to be
in the room uh or the sort of virtual
room if you will the second is how do we
create a a structure a Health Care
System where that can actually happen
with efficiency where it can be
reimbursed appropriately but that's what
we should be doing and then the Third
Leg of that is the the group experience
for patients right and there's
increasingly in more clinics and healthc
Care Systems around the country that are
working on creating group experiences
where patients who all let's say are
working on diabet on their diabetes uh
come together let's say once a week and
they meet uh with the healthcare
practitioner that might be an addition
to their individual appointments but
there is so much power in groups coming
together uh groups of patients who can
find Community who can help each other
learn from each other's experiences uh
that's highly underutilized right now in
medicine um but to really do this well
Andrew I think means that we have to we
have to pull back from the model we have
had for years in medicine which has been
a very a highly individual type model
which says okay you go to your doctor
you see your doctor oneon-one you get
everything you need maybe you need to go
see a specialist okay then you wait a
few weeks get another appointment Drive
30 miles go see somebody else maybe
they're connected to the electronic
health system maybe they're not maybe
they know what was discussed maybe they
they don't maybe they'll call and talk
to their primary care doctor but maybe
they won't because they're too busy and
then you as a patient are stuck trying
to piece all this together while often
in pain well yeah in in physical and
emotional anguish I'm not referring to
my own experience although I've had you
know mild examples compared to what
other people have dealt with but you
know people with chronic pain are
irritable for understandable reasons I
mean it it it's or maybe somebody's
close veering towards suicidal
depression then there's the
interpersonal effects I mean I feel like
the the crisis is is one of a lack of
efficiency and thoroughness and um and
again I'm not throwing stones at the
medical profession I I like you believe
that it's a collection of mostly um
well-meaning people trying to do their
best but the specialist model and the
referral model is incredibly cumbersome
it really is cumbersome and and like you
look I having worked with many medical
professions over the years like these
are colleagues who I deeply admire I
mean like they're there for the right
reasons they want to help people
alleviate suffering but they too are
feeling burned out and frustrated by the
inefficiencies of the system because
I'll tell you one of the greatest
contributors to burnout for doctors and
nurses is a lack of self-efficacy it's
seeing a patient who has a problem in
front of you and feeling like you can't
get them the help uh that they need that
is a the greatest paper cut if you will
uh to the sort of spirit of clinicians
and many find themselves in that
circumstance where they either find that
they know what's needed but the system
is throwing up prior authorizations or
other insurance hurdles and prev their
patient from getting that care or they
are kind of at the edge of their
expertise right this happens to
pediatricians and primary care doctors
more broadly all the time with mental
health right most of the mental health
care that's delivered in this country is
delivered in primary care offices right
now Primary Care offers didn't
necessarily train specifically and only
in mental health yet they find
themselves having to manage a lot of
that including increasingly complex
substance use disorders uh and you
treatment resistant depression and they
need help figuring that out but if you
don't have a lot of resources to get
that referral to collaborate with the
mental health professionals then you're
stuck on your own figuring that out and
so you look I think the pain is being
experienced mostly by patients and but
also very much so by clinicians and
that's why that overhaul is needed and I
I think look a lot of this is you know
I'm not a healthcare Economist per se
but I will say that a lot of this I
think is tied into the business model
that we built around medicine uh the
notion that um you know we're paying
individual people for IND idual services
and individual procedures that are done
uh while that has some Merit in some
cases what we really care about is that
the person is getting efficient
integrated multi-disciplinary care
overall and so when health systems for
example come together and say okay
rather than um sort of focusing on the
amount I'm getting reimbursed for every
procedure we're going to take more of a
value based approach here where we say
okay we've got a certain amount of money
to care for certain people what's the
most efficient way for us to provide
them care
recognizing if we don't do that it's not
only bad for them but our costs in the
long term will go up because we're not
getting reimbursed for every procedure
we're getting reimbursed for the the
care overall care that we're taking for
a patient so there are more of these
value-based models that are are being
adopted uh certainly in 2010 when the
Affordable Care Act was passed and when
uh other measures were taken in the
Obama Administration in Medicare like
that really pushed value based payment
models forward um and again they're not
perfect they've got they need their own
tweaks but I don't think that the
existing Financial structure that we had
in medicine was serving Us in terms of
delivering the kind of
multi-disciplinary integrated efficient
care that we increasingly need tough
problem but through recognition of tough
problems comes good Solutions that's my
belief I'm an optimist at the end of the
day you mentioned mental health uh
lately you've been increasingly vocal
about the crisis of isolation just one
second Andrew before we go there just
one thing I about the tough problems
right you're exactly right and the
problem is the longer we take to
acknowledge and address these tough
problems the more entrenched the
interests become that profit from the
status quo right so if you look at um
the private insurance industry uh right
now there are so many challenges we have
right now with patients and clinicians
saying that they know what care is
needed but it gets denied they know what
care is needed but prior authorizations
you know get grown up there and required
uh even for a medicine that clearly your
patient needs urgently you know I've had
the experience
myself of having a family member who's
needed a medication for an urgent
situation and then being told that the
pharmacy will not fill it because it
requires a prior authorization but that
can't be processed uh until the weekend
is over because no one's in the office
to approve the prior authorization and
you're thinking to yourself does this
make any sense like this is an urgent
situation my family member needs his
medication I've also had the experience
as a doctor of fighting for my patients
who have been denied Care by an
insurance company being on the phone
saying I'm sitting here in front of my
patient I know that they are sick I know
they can't go home I know they need to
be in rehab there's nobody literally to
help them at home but then not having
like the the rehab bed approved by
somebody who's not even there right and
there's also just a a practice that
we've seen time and time again where
insurance companies will also just
burden clinicians with more and more
requests for information before they
will agree to reimburse for services
that have already been delivered for a
patient who needs them which is just
creating more and more barriers hoping
that if you're a small time doc out
there who's got you know your shingle
that you put up you don't have a lot of
resources how are you going to keep
fighting all of this and sending more
and more paperwork and So eventually
you'll just give up um we have a lot of
problems right there in an industry that
should be delivering
care often is doing good things but too
often I think is allowing barriers to be
put up uh to the care that's needed and
this is particularly true with mental
health I know we're going to talk about
that but Mental Health Care is just been
such a difficult thing for people to get
in our country and part of the reason
there are many reasons but one of them
is that insurance companies historically
did not reimburse adequately or in the
same level for mental health care as
they did for physical healthare or if
they did they would only reimbursed for
a limited number of sessions that you
could have uh but how if if you're a mom
out there who sees her child struggling
uh with depression you're really worried
um you don't want to be told you know
what uh you can only get three sessions
that's it what are you supposed to do
after three sessions right uh and so
what has happened is that even though in
2008 there was a law p called the
addiction uh equity and mental health
parity law even though that was passed
to try to close that Gap there were many
ways that insurance companies were
skirting it right so one the law wasn't
even being adequately were enforced for
many years but two insurance companies
sometimes would say okay you know we're
reimbursing adequately but when you look
in the network they had very few
provider so you really couldn't access
somebody right so that was a problem for
patients and then the other challenge is
that they would say okay you can see
somebody but you've got to complete this
prior authorization have that completed
by your primary care doctor Etc again
throwing up more and more barriers so
very recently in fact just a few weeks
ago um President Biden just announced
that we are from as an Administration
putting out a proposed rule to actually
strengthen uh the mental health parody
law to prevent some of these what I
think of as abusive practices because
they're preventing people who need care
from getting it and if you've ever been
as I know many people have been who are
listening to this if you've ever been in
a situation where you or somebody you
love has struggled with a mental health
concern what you need in that circum
cumstance is help you don't need to be
filling out paperwork you don't need to
be waiting 3 months to actually get care
you don't need to show up and be told
only you only have two more appointments
you need to know that help is there when
you need it and a lot of these uh
denials are are being issued to people
who have done their their part of the
bargain they' paid their premiums
they've held up their end of the bargain
and Care should be there for them when
they need it so anyway this is something
that upsets me a lot because I just I
have seen too many patients over the
years struggle without the care that
they deserve and should get because the
barriers that are being thrown up uh by
industry but I say all that just to say
that when you take on big problems you
will run up against entrenched interests
and that's a fight we have to take on we
can't shy away from it we can't say you
know this is politically too difficult
like one of the things I'm very proud of
is that we're finally negotiating on
drug prices through the Medicare program
something that should have been done
decades ago but it's finally happening
now um you know the administration just
decided this has got to happen it was
passed by Congress this is good uh
and it just it makes no sense that we
would pay more than we need to and pass
the cost on to taxpayers uh when we can
negotiate and we got to get look you got
to if you're collecting taxes as
Government you should be doing your best
to make sure every one of those dollars
is being spent well right cuz somebody
took money out of their paycheck uh
didn't use it for their family didn't
use it for their kids and they gave to
the government for good reason because
that supports First Responders police
officers a whole bunch of services that
we need but the responsibil in
government is to make sure that money is
being used well and to pay more for
medications than we should makes no
sense at all especially for patients and
taxpayers so clearly some steps in the
right direction are occurring while on
the topic of mental health um let's talk
about the isolation crisis um what is
the isolation crisis what aspects of
mental and physical health is is it
impacting and then um perhaps most
importantly what can we each and all do
about it
mhm well this is one of those issues
that I if you had told me Andrew 10
years ago hey you and I are going to be
sitting here talking about loneliness
and isolation I would have said I don't
think so but I was really educated by
people I met across the country about
the fact that this was a real problem
and the truth is it was familiar to me
because of my own personal experiences
you know as as a child I struggled a lot
with a sense of loneliness and isolation
I was really shy as a kid I was pretty
introverted and I wanted to to make
friends and hang out with other kids but
it took me a while to actually build
those relationships so um I spent a lot
of time feeling left out you know there
were times when I I I I would like when
in elementary school and there were days
where I pretended I had a stomach ache
and so that my mom wouldn't make me go
to school and it wasn't cuz I was scared
of a test or a teacher cuz I didn't want
to like walk into the cafeteria one more
time
and be scared that there was nobody to
sit next to or that no one would want me
to uh to be at their bench um I as I
know what it feels like and I also know
what the shame is like because I never
told my parents about this well I never
told anyone about that um because even
though I knew my parents loved me I just
felt like hey if I'm feeling this lonely
it means something's wrong with me I'm
not likable I'm not lovable I'm
something's got to be it's got to be my
fault in some way it was only years
later Andrew when I talked to friends
from grade school that I realized that a
lot of them were feeling the same thing
we were all struggling by ourselves uh
no one really knew it and I came to see
a lot of this as a doctor when I was
taking care of patients and I never took
a class on loneliness in medical school
it wasn't part of our residency
curriculum yet when I showed up in the
hospital I found that the patient who
had come in with a diabetic wound
infection or who had come in um you know
because they had had a heart attack when
I sat down and talked to them often in
the background they would talk about how
lonely they were sometimes I would ask
them hey you know I need to have a
difficult conversation about uh your
diagnosis is there somebody you'd want
me to call to be with you during this
time and too often the answer was you
know I wish there was but there's nobody
I'll just have the conversation by
myself so but it was when I was Surgeon
General I realized that those
experiences weren't limited to me and my
patients but they were incredibly common
and two things I learned when I dug into
the data Andrew was number one that
loneliness is exceedingly common with
one in two adults in America reporting
measurable levels of loneliness but the
numbers are actually even higher among
young adults and adolescents the numbers
and among uh youth actually depending on
the surveys you look at are between 70
to 80% uh who say that they are
struggling with loneliness so that's the
first thing that I learned but the
second thing was how consequential
loneliness was I used to think
loneliness was just a bad feeling what I
came to see in digging into the
scientific lit literature was that
feeling socially disconnected being
lonely and isolated was actually
associated with increased risk of
depression anxiety suicide but also an
increased risk of cardiovascular disease
of dementia and these are not small
risks we're talking about 29% increase
in the risk of coronary heart disease
31% risk and the increased risk of
stroke 50% increased risk of dementia
among older people increased risk of
premature death and the mortality impact
of of loneliness by the way and
loneliness and isolation uh is
comparable uh you know to the mortality
impact of many other illnesses in fact
it's even greater than the mortality
impact we see associated with obesity
which is something we clearly recognize
as a public health issue so you put all
this together and for me one of the key
takeaways is that loneliness and
isolation are critical public health
challenges that are hiding behind the
curtain behind this wall of stigma and
shame and unless we talk about it and
address it unless we reconcile what's
been happening to us over the last 50
years where fewer and fewer people are
participating in community organizations
where more and more people are feeling
isolated then we're not going to be able
to repair the fraying foundations of
society which are grounded fundamentally
in our connection to one
another you mentioned Community
organizations um could you elaborate on
uh you know growing up in the 70s and
80s
I was exposed to like Community soccer
teams swim team there was a community
pool these were all public uh things uh
there were um churches synagogues and
mosques are we not seeing as much
participation in those those types of
organizations anymore and what other
types of organizations are are out there
that um you know come to mind when you
think about the isolation crisis yeah so
there there are several factors that
have led to us being as isolated as we
are one of them as you mentioned is the
decline in participation in community
organizations and this isn't a recent
phenomenon this has been happening over
the last half century in America we've
seen lower participation in faith
organizations in recreational leagues in
service organizations and other
community groups that used to bring us
together and I think you know we can
talk about the reasons why that has been
the case U but one of the key
consequences of that is that
people don't have places where they can
come together and get to know one
another especially across differences so
we actually associate more and more with
people who are like us but this has also
been fueled by a few other factors uh
that are going on at the same time one
is that just from a cultural perspective
as modernity has arrived not just in the
US but in other other countries we've
seen that people are more mobile right
they move around more we don't always
stay in the community that we grew up in
uh we tend to even if we move somewhere
else for a school we may go somewhere
else for a job we may change jobs and
move somewhere else we are leaving
behind communities that we grew up with
that we went to school with that we
worked with and I'm not saying that's
all a bad thing right we're having more
opportunities and that's a really good
thing but I think one thing that we have
not accounted for is the cost of these
changes right if we know what the costs
are of certain actions we may still take
those actions but we may find ways to
mitigate the the costs we may in this
case invest more in our relationships be
more conscious about reaching out to
other people going to visit at them uh
but that has been a a quiet but but
devastating Consequence the other piece
with modernity is that we have more
convenience in our life which means that
we also don't need to see other people
to get certain things done like buying
groceries or mailing an item out or
getting something from the store I can
sit in the comfort of my home and have
everything just come to me now on the
one hand that's incredibly efficient
right but I think efficiency is an
interesting thing because it's only one
factor we should be considering in our
lives there too we have to ask the cost
and one interesting thing about Co is
many people in the first year of Co when
we were all separated from one another
you know when we finally came back
together again I had so many people who
said to me you know what I expected to
miss my parents and my siblings and my
friends not being able to see them what
I didn't
expect was missing the strangers that I
saw at the coffee shop or the folks who
I ran into the grocery store or seeing
neighbors as I walked down the street
like I actually missed that more than I
thought I would so we have lost out on
some of those interactions and those
loose ties but the final thing to keep
in mind also is about what is happening
with how we are using social media
technology which I think is
fundamentally transformed how we
interact with one another and how we see
ourselves and each other and this is
particularly true for young people uh
who are growing up as digital natives
but what has happened there I worry is
that and and it's not that social media
is all bad just to be clear you know
technology look I'm I'm a believer that
in technology broadly speaking you know
I'm a user of technology I spent seven
years building a tech company I'm a
Believer in Tech but I think whether
technology helps or hurts us is about
how it's designed and ultimately about
how it ends up being used and what we've
seen with social media as well is that
uh for many people it ended up leading
to in-person connections being replaced
with online connections um we came to
somehow value and
um almost seek out more and more
followers and friends on social media
feeling like somehow that made us more
connected but the nature of dialogue
also changed like as human beings we
evolved over thousands of years to not
just understand the words someone is
saying but to hear the tone of their
voice to see their facial expression
like you and I are sitting across and
and we're both processing like our body
language right and I'm seeing you nod
your head and I'm seeing your eyes
focused like all of that matters to how
we communicate um but also like you and
I are less likely to say something
hurtful right now to one another because
we can see each other if I said
something to hurtful to you like i'
probably see the the pain or
consternation on your face and that
might give me pause right when you're
communicating online with other people
without any of that information or with
any of the uh sort of barriers if you
will that make you pause before you hurt
someone it leads to a very different
kind of communication uh one that can be
quite hurtful at times and I also think
that one thing people many people don't
recognize is that to communicate with
somebody else and reach out and build a
relationship with someone it actually
takes a certain amount of self-esteem to
do that you have to believe the other
person's going to want to hang out with
you they're going to see something
valuable in you and for many young
people what has happened uh and I think
frankly for many older people too is
their experience on social media has
shredded their self-esteem as they
constantly comparing themselves to other
people like when you and I were growing
up uh you know in the ' 80s we we
compared ourselves to other people too
right people have from Millennia but
what's fundamentally different now is
that in a given day you can compare
yourself to thousands of images that you
see online that's actually literally
what people young people tell me I do
roundtables with college students and
high school students all the time around
the country and the three things they
tell me most consistently about their
experience of social media is it makes
them feel worse about themselves worse
about their friendships but they can't
get off it because the platforms are
designed to maximize the amount of time
they spend on them so you put all of
this together and I think what has
happened is that we're talking more but
we understand each other less we have a
lot of
information but we're lacking in the
wisdom that comes from Human
Relationships uh and I think that that's
really hurt us you know we see it
certainly in the data that tells us
about mental and physical health
outcomes but there's also the human
suffering component Andrew like it's
really heartbreaking for me to travel
around the country to hear hear from
people of all ages often in quiet
whispers about their struggles with
isolation about how they feel like they
just don't matter at all about how they
feel like they just don't have a place
where they belong and it's these are
people on the outside look perfectly
fine right they're posting happy things
online to Folks at work they're seeming
like everything's going great this is
why I always tell people like you
loneliness is a great masquerader it can
look like withdrawal and sadness it can
look like anger and irritability
it can look like aloofness as well and
so it's only when we stop to ask someone
how they're doing when we take pause for
a moment to maybe reflect on what's
happening in their life that we realize
that wow the majority of people in our
country are actually struggling with
loneliness yeah I'm a firm believer that
our nervous system evolved under
conditions of close interpersonal and
direct connection and um to suddenly
throw a technology in front of ourselves
that deprives our nervous system of its
normal development is it's clearly going
to lead bad places it's also um clear to
me as based on what you just described
that you know when we go on social media
we see something but they don't really
see us you know hence perhaps why people
get um aggressive in the comment section
um you know they they want to be heard
yeah um we want to be seen I think all
of us want to be seen and see other
people yeah and uh social media doesn't
allow for it so easily um I also so know
that a lot of young people will
congregate with their friends to play
video games online but that's different
you're you're essentially showing up as
an avatar MH and when you when we were
kids we also played different characters
in our in our games um but oh so
different now um do you think that there
will be a youth Rebellion movement
against um these kinds of Technologies I
mean there's a long history of of young
people rebelling against the the stuff
that's been put in front of them and
they're like nope no more we're going to
Rebel in fact that was the way that
youth overcame the um the nicotine e
epidemic if you recall it was the
advertising pitching them against or
pitting them excuse me against um
wealthy cackling older men in chair in
rooms counting their money that was what
actually was successful in getting kids
to not smoke because kids have a
rebellious streak as opposed to when
they were told hey smoking is terrible
for you your lungs are going to fill
with cancer kids didn't stop smoking
teens stop smoking it was you know
Rebellion has been um baked into our
nervous system uh in the Adolescent and
teen years so do you see a rebellion
against this um social isolation our
kids going to start putting away their
phones and hanging out together again
and that's going to rescue us and that's
a way of saying what can we do for them
what can they do for themselves and what
can we do as adults because there are a
lot of um the silent suffering is the
thing I also really worry about yeah so
it's a good question and I think there
is already uh a movement that's building
among young people
to create distance between them
themselves and their devices and
particularly social media and it it's
it's cropping up in different ways I'm
meeting more and more some of these are
organized efforts but I'm also meeting
more uh families uh where the parents
and kids together have decided that
they're going to delay using social
media and you know till past middle
school or in some cases even later or
where they're deciding that they're
going to draw boundaries around social
media use or they're going to replace
their smartphone with a dumb phone that
allows them to do things like text and
make phone calls and use maps and and
all that stuff but doesn't necessarily
have social media apps on it now this is
still a small minority and and we're
dealing with a bit of a network effect
here right because if you're the only
one who's not on social media uh in your
middle school class then you might feel
left out which is why it's so important
for parents to and and kids actually do
this together but I do think that to use
your analogy with smoking
that one thing that I I think many young
people bristle against is this notion of
being manipulated and used for the
profit you know of a social media
platform and the reality is that the
again we've talked about how the
fundamental business model is for most
social media platforms is built on how
much time you spend on those platforms
that translates to ad revenue and that
translates to the bottom line whereas
what I care about as a parent as search
in general is about how well that time
is being spent is it actually
contributing to the health and
well-being of a young person or or is it
not is it actually harming them and this
is where I think when I go out and talk
to young people about this number one
I'm so impressed by a lot of young
people because they they already have a
lot of these insights they're the ones
living it right they're not thinking
that this is all you know perfect and
and it's all a pure benefit here they're
the ones telling me that it makes them
feel worse about themselves and and
their friendships but they also having a
hard time getting off of it uh because
again of how these platforms are
designed so about a third of adolescence
are saying that they're staying up till
midnight or later on week nights using
their devices and a lot of that is
social media use and this takes away
from sleep which we know and you know
better than anyone is so critical to the
mental health and well-being of all of
us but of young people in particular who
are at a critical phase uh you know of
development um the other thing that is
very concerning to me is nearly half of
adolescents say that using social media
has made them feel worse about their
body image as they're constantly
comparing themselves to others online
and we used to think that this is just
girls who are experiencing this and yes
it is uh a lot of young girls who are
experiencing these body image issues but
now it's increasingly uh boys as well so
this is happening across the board but
the other piece I think that concerns me
thinking about mental health symptoms is
that you look at how much time uh kids
are using social media on average
adolescent are using it for three and a
half hours a day on average so just
social media just social media and that
means many you're using it for far more
than that and what you're finding though
is that for adolescence who use it 3
hours or more in a given day their risk
of anxiety or depression symptoms double
right so and if they average uses three
and a half days that means that millions
of kids all across our country the
majority of our kids are are at risk
here and so you know you put all this
together and and it paints a very
concerning picture whatever benefits
there may be for some kids of using
social media and there's some and we lay
out some of this in our advisory on
social media some kids find social media
is a great way to express themselves to
reach other people to find support
especially if they're from a community
that doesn't have a lot of folks who
like them around uh it can be really
reassuring to connect with others but we
can't say that just you know that to get
those benefits we have to subject our
children to all of these other harms
right like kids are experiencing
exposure to harmful content to
harassment and bullying online six out
of 10 uh adolescent girls are saying
they've been approached by strangers on
social media and ways that made them
feel very uncomfortable um our kids are
also finding that Health promoting
activities in their lives are being
cannibalized by their use of social
media that it's detracting from time for
Sleep inperson interaction physical
activity and the erosion of self-esteem
really concerns me as well because you
know you need that not just for social
interaction but like look as a as a
father I want my children to grow up
being confident about who they are being
confident enough to be authentic as they
up in the world to not feel like they
need to create some brand that's
different from who they fundamentally
are just to sell that to the world I
want them to know who they are and to be
comfortable being who they are and to
encourage other people to do the same to
support them in their efforts to be
authentic that's what I want my kids to
do that's not what's happening to a lot
of kids on social media so I think we
not only need more kids to understand
this and to support them in their
efforts to create space and sacred
spaces away from social media but we
need to support parents here too cuz
Andrew my big concern with parents is
look we've taken this technology which
is rapidly
evolving which we didn't grow up with as
kids and we've told parents you manage
it all on your own we put the entire
burden on parents and kids to manage
this um you know when we were growing up
you remember the motor vehicle
fatalities were really high uh in
America and we didn't say okay you know
what that's just the price of Modern
Life we just have to accept it and keep
moving on with our lives we said hold on
we don't have to go back to horses and
Buggies but we also don't need to accept
this death rate we need to make this
experience safer and so we put in place
with the advocacy and support of
incredible groups like Matt and others
across the country that me Mothers
Against Drunk Driving ultimately the
government put in place safety standards
that got us seat belts airbags crash
testing to make sure the frame of cars
were robust in the setting of an
accident and that help helped us reduce
motor vehicle accidents and deaths and
that's what we need here too like we
need to have the backs of parents and
kids and that means from a policy
perspective putting in place safety
standards to protect kids from exposure
to harmful content from from the
experience of bullying and harassment
and that also protect them from features
that would seek to manipulate them into
excessive use uh which is happening far
too often right now we also need a
policy that requires data transparency
from the company you know researchers
tell us all the time that they these are
independent researchers they tell us
they are having a hard time getting full
access to the data from the social media
platforms about the full impact of the
platforms on the mental health of kids
and as a parent look I I don't when we
bought car seats for my children when
when they were born we looked up the
safety data like many parents we wanted
to make sure the car seats were safe but
if you had told me that hey you know the
manufacturers of these car seats are
actually not disclosing some of the the
data on the impact on children uh but go
ahead and buy it anyway you know I'm
sure other people are buying these car
seats you should be fine I would have
been very disturbed by that right no
parent wants to feel that information is
being hidden from them about the health
impact of products on their kids that's
what we have right now so this is a
place where I think while yes uh and we
we'll we should we'll talk about some
steps parents can take because I want to
get to practical steps of people who are
here as parents or people have kids in
their lives can
take but we we we need policy makers to
step up and step into the void here and
to fill the Gap because this is too much
again to just ask parents to manage
entirely on their own and this isn't
again about telling parents what to do
and restricting them this is about
giving them the support they need so
they have confidence uh when they see uh
you know a technology out there a device
out there a product out there for kids
that they know it's been tested that
it's been studied and that it's actually
safe for their children my understanding
is that in uh countries like China there
are limit
as to how many hours kids can be on
screens period And when I was a kid we
were allowed to watch TV for a certain
number of I think it was a half an hour
or an hour my mom was constantly kicking
us out of the house like literally you
got to leave the house you got to go
down the street and play un fortunately
I liked outdoor activities um nowadays
we also have the issue that a lot of
parents are on their phones at soccer
games and at kids events and so the kids
are modeling their parents yeah um
parents are distracted as well so
there's a lack of social connection
people even an immediate family people
are screened in um you know TV there's
laptops there's multiple phones iPads
people are you more engaged in the
screen portals than often than their own
portals you go to a concert and people
are watching the concert through their
screen so that they can send the same
image that everyone around them is
sending out to the world if you think
about it's kind of crazy um but I guess
they want to capture that unique
experience but uh it's not unique at all
that's the that's the myth that's the
illusion there's nothing unique about
the your post of something that you went
to go see what would be truly unique is
to just experience that in real time
right it's so wild to think about like
what we think of as our unique portal is
actually not unique at all it's what we
do with it learn on my my stance is
glean and learn information online then
go use it in real life come back from
time to time you know maybe an hour a
day maximum or so can I just underscore
the two words you said real life because
that I think is a really important key
here which is that all of real life
isn't happening on social media there's
a whole world out there which I think is
real life which is happening offline and
what's happening online too often is
distorted right it's giving us like like
even just take
um you know just take the images that
that we see of people their uh you know
their summer beach images their like
great vacation images that's not
representative of their entire life of
how they're living their life but we see
that we see people's anger we and their
vital and we come to believe over time
that that's how people feel that's what
people are dealing with and experiencing
their life and and we've just got to get
you your mom I love what your mom did
getting you guys outside um my parents
did the same thing too like we I was
very blessed to have two parents who
didn't come you know they didn't have a
lot of resources growing up they didn't
come to this country with a lot of
resources but the one of the greatest
gifts they G gave us is that they loved
us uncondition Al the other great gift
that they gave us is they pushed us to
just explore to meet people to learn
about the world uh they wanted us
outside playing you know experimenting
just discovering the world you know
riding our bike around the neighborhood
and and that's what we did but right now
two critical things that kids need for
their mental health and development or
two important forces I should say that
are impacting their mental health and
development one is social media but the
second also is the lack of unstructured
plate time uh that kids have like
unstructured playtime is time when we as
kids learn how to negotiate situations
with other kids how to resolve conflict
how to recognize what's going on in
someone else's you know eyes before they
say something we learn how to
collaborate and play with other kids
this a lot you learn on the playground
as it turns out but I worry that right
now that we've almost somehow made that
kind of unstructured time seem
inefficient you know we've set these
standards uh for our kids that they need
to be uh you know getting fancy jobs and
into fancy colleges and making an x
amount of money and the path to doing
that is you know to be enrolled in X
number of activities after school and to
do all this stuff in school and their
lives are so hyper structured um that I
worry that the time to just play to be
creative to reflect and think to just
have unstructured time with other kids
has evaporated and I think that that
also is hurting the mental health and
wellbeing of our children I love the
idea that that unstructured play time
could be framed in the accurate context
of the nervous system developing the way
it was supposed to develop I mean I
would argue that um success is going to
be easiest for children that engage in
the real world more in fact there's
great risk to posting everything that
you do online we've seen some examples
of that preventing people from getting
into or staying in college based on
things they said or did previously that
they shouldn't have said or done um
that's those are kind of you know
negative highlighted cases but in
general um we know that the the nervous
system thrives on diversity of types of
interactions and social interactions in
particular I'm just restating what you
just said so if ever there was a call
for kids to get out into non-screen life
let's call it um and engage uh their
nervous system that way it without
question is going to benefit them in
terms of their ability to learn and
retain information perform well in
school which is not everything life's
about but let's face it we still live in
a society where hitting those milestones
on a consistent basis are the best is
the best predictor of people being able
to you know live self-sustained lives
build families and that sort of thing so
um you mentioned a few actionable M uh
items for parents as it relates to kids
maybe well not maybe limits their screen
time force them outside in the safe
weather and safe conditions of course
but uh what about adults as well I what
what can we all do um should we be
restricting our screen time to X number
of hours per today I mean you're the
Surgeon General if you had a magic wand
which I realize you don't um and you
could make a uh a highly informed
recommendation about what the thresholds
for too much uh time on social media are
um what would it be two hours three
hours yeah it's it's a good question and
let me actually go through some of these
things that parents can can do for kids
and that we can all do for ourselves
with kids in particular um what I would
do specifically with social media is and
this is this is frankly what I'm
planning to do with my wife for our kids
as they grow up number one I would seek
to delay the use of social media past
Middle School uh at at minimum and I
know that that is hard to do at a time
where all kids are on social media and
you don't want your child to be the only
one left out and to be lonely as a
result so that means no account of their
own means no account of their own okay
and I would make see to the best of your
ability see if there are other parents
that you can partner with to do this
because it's hard to do alone as a
parent but it's also if there are other
parents you're partnering with that
means there other kids who are also
delaying you so that means your child is
not alone and I think if you start the
conversation with other parents you'll
realize a lot of them are worried about
the same things you are they may have
thought about delaying you but they also
don't want their kid to be the only one
so this becomes a numbers challenge but
partnership can help us if your child's
already on social media what I'd
recommend is to create sacred spaces in
their lives that are technology free and
specifically I would think about the
hour before bedtime and throughout the
night as time that you want to protect
because kids are losing not just sleep
because they're going to sleep later
because they're on their devices but
they're also waking up in the middle of
the night maybe to use a bathroom maybe
to get some water and then they get back
on their devices again so the quality of
their sleep is being significantly
impacted by access to those devices
during the night so I would protect that
time hour before bed throughout the
night I would also create make sure meal
times uh were Tech free zone so that
people actually that you talk to one
another you see one another and time
with friends and family members when
you're out you know at a birthday party
Etc make that Tech free time let them
focus on their time with other people
those three Tech free zones can do a
world of good uh to help your child and
then the last thing I'd recommend here
the many things I think parents could do
is to start a dialogue with your child
about their use of social media um we
don't always know how social media is
making our kids feel uh from the and we
may realize when we talk to them that
they actually have their own concerns
they might say yeah it's not making me
feel really good but it's just like hard
not to be on it everyone's like texting
on this or everyone is uh you know
everyone's you know sharing information
and posting pictures on it I feel like I
need to be on it you can only help them
start to manage that if you know that
that's a challenge that they're having
so opening a conversation so your child
knows that you're not judging them but
you're trying to understand their
experience is important also so you can
help them understand what is not
acceptable for them to experience on
social media if they're being harassed
or bullied by strangers uh that is a
problem you want your child to to tell
you about that to report that um if they
see something posted online that's
really concerning to them let's say they
see a friend post that they're thinking
of taking their own life or harming
themsel in another way you want them to
know that that's important to flag and
to get help you know that they shouldn't
just you know scroll past that so that
conversation is really important and
finally as parents we can lead by
example right and this is hard because
the truth is we've been talking about
social media and youth and that's what
the subject of my search and General's
advisory was on but I have concerns
about adults too I said as somebody
who's had challenges in my own use you
know of social media finding sometimes
it bleeds you know past my bedtime and
I'm realized you know I think m&a
checked something for 5 minutes an hour
later I'm still there you know scrolling
through something uh and sometimes I you
know you know I find myself over the
years I found myself comparing myself
also to posts I see online and unhealthy
ways sometimes I find myself um sort of
pulled into uh content uh that uh you
know ends up being angry and vitriolic
and leaves me feeling worse you know at
the end so I've experienced this as well
and I think as parents one of the
hardest things to do is to follow this
advice we're giving our kids to draw
those boundaries as well and to put our
devices away when we're around our kids
uh one experience I had which sort of I
still feel bad about but which really
helped kind of knock some sense into me
was after my my son was born uh my older
child I was actually I was search in
general at that time you know I had you
know it was lot going on it was busy job
Etc but I wanted to make sure that I
protected bed times uh and meal times
for us to be together as a family yet
one day when I came home you know after
dinner when we were doing the bathtime
and bedtime routine getting my son ready
uh for the night uh my wife was changing
ing his diaper and instead of helping I
was just standing at the side scrolling
through my inbox and my wife who has
infinite patience and is like one of the
most well adjusted people that I know
just paused and she turned to me and
Alice said do you really need to be
doing that right
now and she said just very quietly but I
felt this like such a sense of Shame
when she did that because I was like
what am I doing like this is my infant
child you know and the rare few hours I
have with them during the day and I'm
just scrolling through my inbox in my
phone like like this is terrible and
look I know that all of us do this it
maybe in different contexts but it was a
wake up moment for me because I realized
like one like as you know well as a
neuroscientist we can't really multitask
right we're rapidly task switching right
and that was time in my when I head was
in my inbox and my head wasn't with him
you know and my heart wasn't with him
right and I was just distracted and so
as parents if we can honor those sacred
times you know when we're with our
children to keep our devices away meal
times sleep time as well it's not easy
to do but it really sets a good example
for our kids um all Behavior change that
we're talking about here the kind of
behavior change I've worked with with
patients over the years are physical
activity and diet all of this is harder
to do when we're doing it by ourself
it's a lot easier to do do when we're we
have a couple of friends or family
members who we agree to do this with we
hold each other accountable we encourage
and support each other um it's how I've
been able to make the most successful
Behavior changes I've made in my life
have come about because I have two good
buddies uh Dave and sunny who are my my
part of my brotherhood and the three of
us as brothers talk about health we talk
about our finances we talk about our
family and our friendships and our
failings and we help keep each other
accountable and so I would just
encourage parents like is this sounds
daunting or overwhelming you don't have
to do this alone think about one or two
people other parents who you might want
to do this with and I guarantee you
there a lot of us are struggling with
the same stuff and they would probably
welcome an opportunity to do this in
collaboration with another parent such
spectacular advice that I hope everyone
will follow not just for their kids but
for themselves I think that whether or
not social media is addictive in the in
the true sense of the word is is kind of
meaningless debate at this point it's at
the very least a compulsive behavior for
many of us and as you described it in
example you gave it becomes reflexive
yes we're just you know we're not
necessarily seeking pleasure or looking
to to engage in online battles it's just
it's become reflexive sort of like
finding yourself with your hand in the
refrigerator just you even think about
it you're just doing it so becoming more
conscious of the use uh and thereby more
conscious of the value of putting away
the screens and social media for
extended periods of time each day and
certainly in the middle of the night
folks neuroplasticity brain rewiring
happens in the middle of the night while
you're asleep and I this when you
mentioned kids awake in the middle of
the night looking at their phone I just
I saw you Flinch oh my goodness it pains
me and I've looked at my phone in the
middle of the night I try not to but um
but I'm certainly not in the window of
Maximum plasticity either it's terrible
for everybody but especially terrible
for kids um what you just provided is an
incredible
let's just call it a I'll call it a
mandate you didn't say it but a
suggestion of of teaming up with people
um to become more like-minded around
these issues and to really promote
health I along those lines I I really
want to thank you um first of all for
the conversation today you're incredibly
busy you're responsible for uh an entire
country is worth of um people so to take
time to sit down with me and to discuss
these topics for our audience is it
incredible
appreciated by me and and and by them I
I feel comfortable extending their
gratitude here and uh it's also clear
based on today's conversation that you
face an enormous number of challenges at
the level of budgetary challenges by the
way I'm going to work on that um it's
hard to shut me up um as well as the the
huge array of of issues that you
confront and um and it's clear that it's
a challenge that you've embraced for
many years now under difficult
conditions and that you're clearly
willing to get out and talk to people
and hear their criticism hear their
concerns hear um and learn from them and
so it's been of great benefit to us to
hear and learn from you and I hope this
won't be the the last of our
conversations there's many more topics
to cover but I just really want to thank
you thanks ever so much for the the the
intellectual power uh and the emotional
power that you put into what you do cuz
that is very clear you're a physician
first and you care about your patients
and your patients are all of us so thank
you so much Andrew that's for me just
incredibly kind of you I thank you I
appreciate that and I've loved our
conversation and you know for me what
what I hope most of all
for my kids for our country more broadly
is
that is that we can go deeper like
beneath this these surface issues I I
worry that we find
ourselves disagreeing about and fighting
about online and recognize that there is
a deeper challenge that we are facing
that I think underlies a lot of uh
these the anger and the vitrio and this
issue around how disconnected we become
from one another I think is at the heart
of that I don't think that there's any
policy or program we can Implement
that's going to ultimately fix what Al
Society without fundamentally realizing
that a lot of this is a
manifestation of a society that has
become more disconnected and More
disinvested in one another like over
time and that's just not who we are it's
not how we evolved over thousands of
years it's not how we're going to thrive
in the future so I know that sometimes
when you look at these big intractable
problems uh like widespread loneliness
in the United States that it can seem
like hard to address these but I do want
to encourage everyone to to recognize
that when it comes to human connection
that it is small steps that can make a
big difference because we are hardwired
to connect as human beings and if you if
you just pause for a moment and if you
just think for a moment in your own life
about someone who has been there for you
during a time of great need somebody who
has stood up for you and you couldn't
stand up for yourself someone who's
helped to remind you of why you're still
a good person why you still have worth
and value to add to the world even when
you had lost faith in
yourself you think about their faith in
you about their support for you about
their love for you think about how
healing that
was that's the power that we have to
help each other
heal we are going through an identity
crisis in many ways as a country where I
think we need to ask ourselves who are
we like what defines who we are what are
the set of values that we want to guide
us in our life to guide our
country and I know that it feels like
We're a nation of people who are mean
who only care about ourselves who are
throwing blame and anger at each other
all the time who are pessimistic about
the future but I actually don't think
that's really who we are I think at our
heart we are hopeful and optimistic
people I think in our true nature we are
kind and generous to one another
um in our hearts we we we're
interdependent creatures who recognize
that if someone else is suffering we
want to be out there to support them uh
and who want to want people to be there
to support us as well that's who who we
really are but we have to to make a
Clear Choice here about our identity you
know as as individuals and as a country
and recognize that that choice has real
implications for everything else that
we're talking about here that's the
foundation and when I think about my own
kids growing up like like many parents I
worry about the world uh that that
they're coming into um I I worry that
they're going to use the wrong word even
though their intentions are right and
people are going to blame them or cast
them out you know I worry that they're
going to stumble and fall down and
people are just going to keep walking by
not caring you know because everyone's
living their own life I worried that
they might become someone who does the
same thing to other people right none of
which I want but I want for all of our
kids is for them to grow up in a society
where we care about one another we have
each other's backs we recognize as that
old African proverb goes that we can go
fast if we go alone but if we really
want to go far we go together and that's
what I want for my kids in our country
but that's what we each have the power
to create in our own lives it starts
with the decisions we make but how we
treat one another do we for example
reach out for 5 minutes a day to someone
that we care about do we pick up the
phone and call them to say hey I'm
thinking about you we can all do that
today do we give people the benefit of
our full attention recognizing that
while time is scarce our attention has
the ability to stretch time it can make
five minutes feel like half an hour but
it's a hard thing for people to get
because they're distracted by their
devices but do we give people the
benefit of our full attention and do we
look for ways to serve one another
recognizing that it's through our acts
of service that we actually Forge
powerful con actions but we also remind
ourselves how much value we have to
bring to the world and this is important
in a time when the self-esteem of so
many of us and our young people in
particular is being eroded uh
particularly by their use of social
media so these are the steps that we can
take to build Connection in our life but
the core values I believe that have to
be at the heart of our identity these
values around kindness and generosity
around courage and
service these also have to animate the
decision decisions that we make in our
life about programs we advocate for the
policies we support the leaders we
choose they should all be reflections of
the values that we want to see in our
children and in society more broadly
because I'll tell you that 90% plus of
the decisions leaders make they make
behind closed doors and what's guiding
them in those moments are their values
that's true whether you're the leader of
a company uh or a nonprofit organization
uh or a leader in government so those
values matter and I want us as a country
to speak more about the values that we
choose about the identity uh that we
want to Anchor ourselves to um that's
the way in which I feel like America can
be an even greater Beacon uh of Hope for
the world because the world is
struggling with this too we're not the
only ones who are dealing with
loneliness and isolation who are seeing
anger uh and resentment and vitri all
bubble up uh at extraordinary levels
we're seeing mistrust in institutions
soore
U many countries are experiencing this I
would love America to lead the way in
some ways in showing what it's like to
embrace a more human identity that's
centered around kindness and service and
friendship uh and generosity like to me
all of these values ultimately Andrew
stem from love right love is our
greatest source of power it's our
greatest source of healing uh I say that
as a Doctor Who's prescribed many
medicines over the years but there few
things more powerful
uh then love and its ability to help us
through difficult times and help mend
the wounds seen and unseen uh that we
all carry with us and I think if we
recognize that we recognize that you
know we don't have to have an MD after
our name uh or have gone to nursing
school to be healers we all have the
power to help each other heal like
Andrew we are not fundamentally a nation
of bystanders who just stand by while
other people suffer like We're a nation
of of healers and hop makers who can
restore hope that the future can be
better who can create a better life for
ourselves and the people around us right
now it's what we're capable of it's what
we're built for that's the identity that
I think we now more than ever need to
embrace
amen and thank you for that um I agree
love is definitely the verb that can get
us where we need to go thank you so much
for your words for your um incredible
efforts to support public health and uh
hopefully to continue to support Public
Health uh I know you've been at this a
long time um and we've all benefited and
um and thanks for your open-mindedness
uh especially around some of the
questions that invoke some Challenge and
again for your taking the time to come
talk with us today and uh I really also
enjoyed it it's it's been a real
pleasure and there was a lot of learning
for me and um like I said before uh I
hope it won't be the last time I hope
not either no I look forward to the next
time to staying in touch and uh just
love this conversation thank you for
what you've done for being this
beautiful channel of information for the
public but it's most more thank you for
who you are you know like who you're
Andrew like comes across very
clearly uh you know when I meet you you
just you have a good heart and you have
good intentions you're man and we need
more people like you in the world thank
you right back at you thank you for
joining me for today's discussion with
Dr vivc Murthy the Surgeon General of
the United States I hope you found it to
be as informative as I did if you're
learning from Andor enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or topics or
guests that you'd like me to cover on
the hubman Lab podcast please put those
in the comment section on YouTube I do
read all the comments in addition please
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not on today's episode but on
many previous episodes of The hubbin Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for Focus the hubman Lab podcast has
partnered with momentous supplements and
we did that for several reasons first of
all their ingredients are of the very
highest quality second of all they tend
to focus on single ingredient
formulations which make it easy to
develop the most cost-effective and
biologically effective supplement
regimen for you and third momenta
supplements ship internationally which
we realize is important because many of
you reside outside of the United States
to see the supplements discussed on the
hubman Lab podcast go to live mous
spelled o us so it's Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media you can do so by
going to huberman lab on all social
media platforms so that's Instagram
Twitter now called X LinkedIn Facebook
and threads on all of those platforms I
cover science and science related tools
some of which overlaps with the content
of the hubman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from the content
covered on the huberman Lab podcast
again that's hubman lab on all social
media platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a zero cost monthly newsletter that
includes podcast summaries as well as
toolkits so toolkits for sleep toolkits
for Learning and plasticity toolkits
related to dopamine regulation and much
more again it's all zero cost you simply
go to hubman lab.com go to the menu tab
scroll down to newsletter and simply
enter your email and we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with the US Surgeon General
Dr Vivic Murthy and last but certainly
not least thank you for your interest in
science
[Music]